ich
Oh, muss man trinken, Sekunde, Sekunde
So jetzt habe ich was zu trinken am start und chat was habe ich verpasst?
Tritze, moin, ja was gibt es neues? Erzählt mal, ich habe nicht so viel mitgekriegt die letzten
Tage. Mich hat ja Corona etwas weg. Gatschi Bast. Carlsson, Dankeschön für 32 Monate Massive
Subscription hier. Ja, das war aber richtig richtig Corona C oder? Wie viel ist Corona man war das?
Also es ging wirklich ordentlich ab, also ich sage euch schön war das nicht. Also nochmal
brauche ich das auf jeden Fall nicht kann ich euch sagen. Ich habe noch ein bisschen Husten, aber ich
fühle mich auch noch ziemlich ziemlich kaputt. Also wenn ich ein bisschen rumgelaufen bin draußen,
ich war jetzt schon wieder ein bisschen ein bisschen wandern kann man sich nennen ein bisschen ein
bisschen rumlaufen draußen eine Stunde danach war ich erst mal im Arsch also ich habe ich bin
die Woche noch krank geschrieben das ist auch notwendig und ich hoffe danach geht's wieder aber
ich muss sagen das am irritierendsten an ganz Corona ist nichts zu riechen oder nichts zu
jetzt schmecken schmecken ist also geschmeckt habe ich eigentlich die ganze zeit was aber ich
rieche nichts und jetzt auch nur noch so ein bisschen also noch noch nicht wirklich wieder
wieder komplett also es ist sehr komisch aber das haben ja irgendwie 50 60 prozent der leute also
da mache ich mir jetzt keine gedanken ich muss auch nicht was trinken dabei weil mein hals ist
noch ultra trocken und ich muss laufend noch husen aber insgesamt glaube ich habe ich das
meist jetzt als kröpste echt überstanden zwar wirklich kann ich nicht spaßig sage ich euch also
ich will den scheiß nicht noch mal haben das war aber richtig zwar richtig wie hast du die
zeit verbracht ich habe zum größten teil im bett gelegen und ich habe videos geguckt youtube
und was ich gemerkt habe was ganz was ganz kacke ist ist nachts im bett liegen ohne irgendwas laufen
ich habe dann teilweise sogar radio angemacht oder so hauptsache dass irgendwas gedudelt ist im
hintergrund also richtig kacke ja ich habe auch mal ein probe arbeitstag verpasst konnte ich nicht
machen weil korona gucken was wir das irgendwie umlegen aber insgesamt ich glaube zum größten
teil habe ich jetzt habe ich jetzt geschafft covid champion also das waren kann ich dir sagen
also richtig angefangen hat es am 30 jahre 30 war wahrscheinlich letzte also hier also freitag
hat es eigentlich schon angefangen freitag hat schon angefangen 29 also hier ja also das
waren jetzt 12 tage ungefähr bis heute ich bin also ich bin relativ schnell negativ getestet mit
schnelltest das war aber nicht dazu geführt dass es irgendwie besser geworden ist also ich
war irgendwie schon am sechsten tag oder so negativ in den schnelltest ja ja ich habe doch gesagt ich
habe euch doch erzählen ich habe mich bei ein paar beworben bei einem wollte ich probe arbeitstag
machen benutze normalerweise auch die monka w aber ich finde die text to speech text to
speech aus frage so lustig sollberg gesucht ein devops engineer na dann ne kündigung ist noch nicht
raus ich weiß auch nicht ob ich kündige müssen wir gucken das hängt bei mir davon ab wie sich
das weiter mit home office entwickelt und wie wie das mit dem probe arbeitstag läuft wie was man
sich da im endeffekt unterm strich da noch einigt also jetzt nicht so als will ich das morgen abschicken
aber ich will einfach mal ein bisschen gucken und ich muss sagen ich hatte echt glück also die
erste sache wo ich mich da beworben habe beziehungsweise jetzt ein probe arbeitstag
machen will die hat mir wirklich gut gefallen und passt auch gut zu dem was ich machen will
und schon gemacht habe also insofern schauen wir mal kommetsbank champ ne mit der kommetsbank
habe ich nichts zu tun aber bei uns sind auch nicht viel besser der zweite strich ist weg
naja mittlerweile kannst du dir über telefon telefon das muss ich euch erzählen leute aber
also ich würde es jetzt keinem empfehlen das großartig auszunutzen erstens die meisten
führungskräfte kennen so ihre üblichen verdächtigen und zweitens ist es im endeffekt
für alle scheiße wenn es zu sehr ausgenutzt wird aber da muss ich was erzählen also ich
corona ich habe schnell test gemacht und mir ging es auch nicht gut also ich habe corona und
rufe ich rufe ich bei einem arzt an bei mir und die meinen zu mir ja dann müssen sie pcr test machen
ich mache kein pcr test ich fahre nirgendwo hin ich bleibe jetzt daheim sitzen ich bin krank ich
fahre jetzt nicht durch die weltgeschichte mal ein pcr test also bin ich einfach daheim geblieben
bin ich einfach daheim geblieben und hab dann im montag wo ich also ich kenne leute ich habe 20
schnelltests oder so ich hatte so ein 40er pack von amazon ihr kennt mich ihr wisst dass ich immer
große packungen große packungen kaufe ich hatte bei amazon amazon antigen
ja genau die die gibt es in der 40er packung erst mal 40er pack corona test am start gehabt
so also leute ich habe massig ich habe massig massig test gemacht ja ich habe teilweise wirklich
drei tests am tag gemacht ja zumindest ja massig test also ich habe die ganze tüte voll berge
corona test zumindest zumindest hatte ich dann das problem ok mein arzt zu dem ich normalerweise
gehe nicht da hat urlaub andere arzt der meinte irgendwie gehen sie mal pcr test machen also was
habe ich gemacht ab runtergeladen ab runtergeladen erst teleklinik dann doktor.de doktorn nordic ab
was auch immer und habe mich dort für die videosprechstunde angemeldet und ich muss sagen
ohne scheiß leute das ist wirklich gar nicht schlecht ich habe mich da angemeldet du musst
du musst die sachen von einem krankenkassenkärtchen abtippen und dann wirst du so ein paar sachen
gefragt wie zum beispiel haben sie fieber oder kopfschmerzen gliederschmerzen husten und so
sachen wirst du da abgefragt und dann habe ich das durchgeklickt und 35 minuten später hatte
ich den arzt am start da musst du dann die kamera anmachen das sieht dann so ein bisschen
naja gut das ist halt sehr geschönt jetzt aber so sieht das aus 35 minuten später hatte ich
den arzt aus berlin der meint ja er macht das auch das erste mal und mal gucken wie das jetzt
funktioniert ja da habe ich dir mein corona test gezeigt habe ihm auch erzählt dass ich
ein bisschen fieber habe und also an 39 grad fieber und husten muss so und dann hat er
mir eine krankmeldung geschickt die krankmeldung hast du direkt in der app direkt direkt hier
drin nicht privat das dann hast du eine krankmeldung drin eine ganz normale krankmeldung die du die man
immer bekommt also einmal für dich einmal für arbeitgeber einmal für die krankenkasse und ja
wie die app heißt doktor.de es gibt auch noch app store teleklinik gibt es auch noch die hatten
aber an dem tag irgendwie keinerlei ärzte frei deswegen habe ich die hier genommen und letztendlich
solange es ein echter arzt ist der mir eine echte krankmeldung ausstellt ist mir doch egal
ob das doktor.de oder teleklinik ist oder gibt noch jede menge solcher sachen bei der gelegenheit
habe ich auch festgestellt dass meine krankenversicherung eine app hat wo man den ganzen
kram online einreichen kann was natürlich wieder nicht funktioniert hat weil ich postident machen
sollte ja aber nice so dann habe ich eine krankmeldung bekommen war für die woche krank und
die woche war mein normaler arzt wieder da und jetzt habe ich mich noch mal krank schreiben lassen
für die woche dass ich wieder zeit habe ein bisschen so normale normalen fitnessgrad zu
erreichen dass ich nicht kaputt bin nach fünf fünf minuten irgendwas machen und vor allem ich
sage euch wisst ihr was das schlimmste bei corona war für mich also jetzt auch so immer noch ein
bisschen das ist der brain lag das das das ist glaube ich das ist glaube ich irgendwo selten thema
wenn es um corona geht aber ich hatte übelst und ich habe immer noch übelsten brain lag also
manchmal vergesse ich mittendrin so was ich sagen wollte und so ja richtig 3 hat rast programmieren
ist tatsächlich jetzt keine gute idee doch du musst deine nummer abtippen du musst die nummer
vom krankenkasten von der krankenkasse karte abtippen du musst das abtippen was da vorne
drauf steht und darüber können die das anscheinend abrechnen ich kann nicht besser schmecken ich
würde sagen ich rieche und schmeckt manche sachen nicht mehr deswegen schmecke ich andere sachen
besser oder mehr ja nee bin ich nicht was ich öfters mache ist dass ich manchmal zur ärztin
gehe und das privat also selbst bezahle einfach zum hautarzt zur hautarzt vorsorge hautkrebs
vorsorge da gehe ich zu einem rein privaten arzt und bezahle das auch komplett selbst einfach weil
schneller geht und deutlich ordentlicher und und besser gemacht wird ja das kann ich mir
vorstellen also pizza habe ich keine gegessen das höchste der gefühle ihr wisst ja ich habe die
letzten monate eh relativ für meine für meine verhältnisse relativ gesund gegessen also ich
habe mir jetzt aber einmal nach corona weil ich halt übelst hunger hatte habe ich mir einmal ein
burger menü bestellt komplett und das das habe ich geschmeckt aber nicht so richtig
gerochen das ist das ist komisches gefühle was kostet die hausuntersuchung ich glaube
die ist am ganzen körper ja ich glaube was habe ich bezahlt irgendwas um 100 euro irgendwas um 100
euro aber die machen das auch wirklich ordentlich du musst dich dann dahin legen dann wird das
abfotografiert manches mit wird beleuchtet wird sich unter mikroskop angeguckt die sind dann auch
nächstes jahr quasi in ihrer aufzeichnung wie es letztes jahr aussah und so viel besser also das
gesetzlich zu machen ist richtig hängen geblieben wenn du zum hautarzt gehst gesetzlich versichert
dann brauchst du ein halbes jahr bis du dran kommst und dann guckt sich das überhaupt nicht
an genau genau ich war da irgendwie eine halbe stunde drin das letzte mal also das bezahle ich
dann gerne selbst und da gehe ich auch gleich zum arzt der nur privat versicherte oder oder selbst
zahler nimmt weil dann geht es einfach schneller die sind auch deutlich entspannter diese netter
sowohl der arzt als auch die sprechstundenhilfe die haben mehr zeit die kannst was fragen natürlich
haben wir jetzt halt die könne auch jeden scheiß abrechnen ja ja also hautarzt hautarzt lohnt sich
auf jeden fall das selbst zu bezahlen gibt noch ein paar sachen also beim hno arzt war ich auch
schon ein paar mal mit selbst bezahlen also generell selbst bezahlen lohnt sich halt immer wenn es wenn
du wirklich was hast wo du sagst hey das muss ich mal eine angucken aber was jetzt halt nix riesig
grosses ist also so ein mrt oder so willst nicht unbedingt selbst bezahlen oder irgendwelche auf
oder eine operation oder so das willst du gar nicht selbst bezahlen aber so sachen wie ich habe
seit drei wochen husten und irgendwie ins hals entzündung müsste man arzt sich angucken da
willst du nicht erst ein halbes jahr warten bist du entweder ist der der halt schon abgestorben
oder es ist alles in ordnung dann ja da war ich auch schon habe ich angerufen habe gesagt hier so
und so drei wochen halsschmerzen habe ich gesagt ja kommen sie heute mittags vorbei das ist halt
das geile wenn du bei einem arzt anruf wenn du gesetzlich versichert bist dann sagen die dann
zu dir so also die nächsten sieben acht wochen wird das nix da ist das ganz ganz eng haben sie
vielleicht irgendwie eine überweisung mit da gibt es keine zu dringlichkeit sachen markieren
oder so ja ne habe ich nicht okay das dauert halt ewig und wenn du irgendwo anrufst und sagst also
ich bezahle das selbst dann ist es eher umgedreht dass sie sagen so ja wann passt es ihnen denn am
besten vormittags oder nachmittags und dann sagst du ja also am besten ist eigentlich montags
nachmittags oder montags ganzen tag da muss ich aber ja wie sieht es denn aus nächsten montag
elf uhr würde das ihnen passen ja klar bin ich da das ist wirklich unterschied wie tag und nacht
glaubst mir also gerade für so kleinigkeiten die man die sich sagen wir mal so im sag mal
irgendwas bewegen zwischen 50 und 500 euro kann man das ab und zu mal machen und die behandlung
ist besser und die versorgung ist besser und die terminvergabe ist auch besser also kann ich euch
wirklich nur empfehlen für so kleine sachen quallok dankeschön für den zap ja ich merke
beim reden dass ich husten muss also ganz fit bin ich immer noch nicht egal wir gucken uns leute
wir gucken uns wir gucken jetzt einfach mal ein paar videos an da muss ich die ganze zeit ganze
zeit schwätzen übrigens eine eine eine sache habe ich noch eine sache habe ich noch trinken
genau eine sache habe ich noch habe ich irgendwas verpasst frage sogar mal an euch irgendwas
irgendwas wichtiges soll ihr aus der technikwelt oder so verpasst muss euch was zeigen ich habe
neueste neue feifert konstruktion ich meine irgendwas musste ich mir ein bisschen gedanken
drüber machen die letzte in die letzten zwei wochen ich habe mir was bestellt bei amazon und
zwar einen ultraschall sensor 0 2 ich habe mir ein ultraschall sensor bestellt wasserdicht
mal da so ein ding und damit haltet euch fest feifert feifert idee
das ding ich mal ein ordentliches bild enlarge jawoll enlarge mal also das ist ein ultraschall
sensor wasserdicht was ich da gemacht habe ist ich habe das außen ins kellerfenster gehängt
in dem ultraschall sensor lauscht du nicht da machst du abstandsmessungen so und jetzt also
ich habe das außen ans kellerfenster gehauen das ding durch kellerfenster durch innen drinne ist
ein esp 32 dran und jetzt kann der den abstand messen von meinem kellerfenster zu einem auto auf
der straße und daran erkenne ich ob der parkplatz vor meinem haus frei ist oder nicht manchmal ihr
wisst ja ich fahre nicht oft auto aber manchmal kommt das vor und wenn ich bei mir beispielsweise
in die nähe vom haus komme mit dem auto da würde ich immer gerne wissen ist der parkplatz vorm haus
frei oder nicht weil wenn der parkplatz vorm haus nicht frei ist dann muss ich auf den parkplatz
fahren also auf normalen größeren parkplatz um die ecke und wenn ich weiß dass frei ist dann kann
ich dann kann ich direkt ans haus fahren so mit der kamera war das immer ein bisschen blöd festzustellen
und jetzt und jetzt mache ich das folgendermaßen jetzt habe ich einen näherungs sensor in home
assistant also sprich der guckt wenn sich mein auto das habe ich gemacht während ich krank war
er irgendwas muss ich machen kann ich den ganzen tag nur im bett liegen so und das wollte jetzt
sagen genau und ich habe es jetzt im home assistant so eingestellt wenn das habe ich
aber noch nicht ausprobiert wenn ich mich mit dem auto auf zu hause zu bewege kriege ich eine
nachricht geschickt ob parkplatz frei ist oder nicht oder ein parkplatz frei ist kann ich dann
die straße abbiegen und mich vors haus stellen und parkplatz nicht frei ist fahr ich halt um die
ecke auf dem parkplatz ich könnte auch das hof darauf machen und den hof fahren aber ich
bin irgendwie zu faul immer das hof darauf zu machen so was mache ich im corona zustand ja
nicht so schwer ist das nicht leute also das hört sich jetzt vielleicht super kompliziert an aber
wisst ihr was ihr dafür machen müsst das einzige was ihr braucht ist in esp 32 und dieses gerät
schließt das an dann macht ihr das motor drauf und stellt das folgendermaßen ein das ist mega
easy ihr stellt es einfach so ein in das motor fertig und dann geht's einzige sache ich habe
hier unten auch was reingeschrieben ja das einzige ist man muss rx und tx vertauschen
nee das funktioniert mit dem hof da nicht gescheit das hof da ist zu alt
nee nee das funktioniert bräuchten komplett neues hof da also muss einfach einstellen hier
echo sensor und dann kriegt man die entfernung und das geht bis 450 das ist mit dem streben doch
keine so gute idee immer noch immer noch wir können uns einfach jetzt ein paar videos ansatz
russi euch die ganze zeit voll ja es steht noch so viel an leute meine auto meine meine rgb haus
nummer beleuchte muss ich irgendwann auch noch mal fertig bauen ich habe mir vor einer weile
bei aliexpress hausnummern rgb hausnummern bestellt ok nicht wirklich rgb hausnummern ich habe mir
gehäuse bestellt in hausnummer form wo man rgb streifen rein machen kann dann habe ich eine
rgb hausnummer das ist richtig geil da kann ich dann gachi gachi bass sounds nicht sounds
beleuchtung machen dann habe ich dann eine rgb hausnummer korrekt rgb hausnummer weil
ich rgb streifen rein mache richtig nice aber das muss ich auch noch fertig bauen ich habe noch
sehr viele sachen die fertig gebaut werden müssen aber dank diesem sensor habe ich jetzt auch einen
parkplatz sensor weiß ich ob der parkplatz frei ist ok was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an chat das
internet verse ist das jugendwort des jahres aber was ist das für den hintergrund hier weeps weeps
in welche reichweite hat der sensor bis bis zu viereinhalb meter sagen so offiziell ich
sag mal ich denke mal so bis vier meter ist wahrscheinlich sehr optimistisch das wahrscheinlich
sehr optimistisch ja vier und halb wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich dreieinhalb vier was sind das für
ein spruch suck it wishell studio code keine ahnung der typ ist eh weird champ was haben
sonst noch zu dienen fahrschein so viel verdient eine zugbegleiterin jüngster doktorant der uni
feiert von not returning to office geht jetzt auch schon los wir hacken einen web server
oh das video ist bestimmt pains camp videos diesen titel sind meistens pains camp das
müssen wir jetzt gucken alter das war alles gut heute kaum mache ich den stream an und
schwätzen bisschen geht's los meine güle ok auf geht's leute das das müssen wir uns
angucken heck am heck am end content hier ok ich ich predikte ich ich predikte jetzt
mal was bevor das video startet bevor ich predikte mal was bevor das video startet also
ich gehe davon aus dass sie irgendwas zeigen werden mit dass du irgendwo code injecten
kannst weil es nicht richtig es capen oder so auf dem web server im back end das wäre
jetzt meine vermutung weil das ist immer ein dankbares themengebiet da kannst du immer
viel zeigen und es betrifft ja potenziell auch also ist ja in der realität auch manchmal
was was probleme macht gucken wir mal also mafos tutorials gucke ich selten ist gar nicht
warum krieg ich selten vorgeschlagen wenn ich wenn ich ab und zu ganz gerne gucke ist
algorithmen verstehen dann nicht mehr dann nicht mehr algorithmen verstehen heißt sondern
jetzt real name am start hat weil ich mich um ein paar ich ehrlich sagen muss interessiert
mich auch nicht alles aber das sind zum größten teil ganz gute sachen dabei ansonsten gucke
ich eigentlich so gut wie keine deutschen it videos wir hacken einen web server ok was
hast du das mitbekommen obs nee was ist das
ok hdr ok hdr ist jetzt vielleicht für mich nicht so das ist das wichtigste update aha
cute sex das ist gut da sieht es vielleicht ein bisschen moderner aus die fall theme apple
silicon support apple encoder amd encoder application specific audio capture das ist
gut das ist gut das ist cool das ist park wenn das geht das ist gut das ist gut das
ist gut da muss ich da muss man hier unten nicht
mal diesen komischen krab über den wind ausmixer machen ja ein video rtx ja das haben sie
ja schon eine weile drinne so ähnliche sachen zumindest obs web sockets an dass ich es über
zweiten bildschirm steuern kann ok auch gut ich habe keine ahnung was rs
rt und rist output sind im timestamp formate oder so keine ahnung send youtube chat message
brauche ich mich ok multiview ok ja das ist gut das war teilweise
richtig ja kram für den kram richtig richtig in obs 1 dazu alleine also das also was ich
gut finde jetzt auf den ersten blick ist eindeutig dass ihr application specific audio capture
das ist das ist ziemlich ziemlich pog hast du nicht sogar collaborated mit ja habe ich
und wir wollten schon aber das liegt an mir nicht an ihm wir wollten schon lange wieder
was aufnehmen aber ich habe es total schleifen lassen wir wollten ein video machen zum thema
kann man alles hexorn um also ein paar vorurteile da aufzuräumen so nach dem motto dass jeder
denkt irgendwie super krasse dinger wäre nötig gewesen um seinen account zu verlieren ja die
meisten leute denken ja wirklich eher dass die google anmeldungen problem hat anstatt
dass sie sich in keylogger eingefangen haben und 99 prozent der fälle haben sie sich in
keylogger eingefangen und die google anmeldung ist absolut in ordnung ist obs für linux
basierte us eigentlich gut ja geht so es ist ja das einzige was du verwenden kannst also
entweder geht es oder es geht nicht durch kratzer gibt ja nichts anderes was du sinnvoll
verwenden kannst einfach dass sie übersetzen an der macht auch gute videos interessant
kenne ich noch nicht ja wir müssen auf jeden fall den video sagen dass es sich halt einfach
bei vielen sachen gar nicht lohnt ja angreifbar ist theoretisch alles in irgendeiner art und
weise aber bei vielen sachen lohnt sich einfach gar nicht was was willst du dich riesig anstrengen
für den account von oma erna wenn es tausende andere sachen viel einfacher gibt so aber
wir gucken was man wir hacken einen webserver leute ich habe ein ungutes gefühl beim titeln
solcher videos aber schauen wir mal schauen wir mal im heutigen video hacken wir einen
webserver von dem haben wir schon ein paar sachen geguckt da weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr
ob die gute oder schlecht war ich glaube die waren ganz ok leise ich freue mich wieder
hier zu sein und ich glaube es wird sehr spannend ein bisschen komische lautstärke abmischung
oder ja hier genau das das gefühl hatte ich auch also ich bin auch der meinung wahrscheinlich
kommt irgendwie in der stelle wo man irgendwas injecten kann ja würde ich jetzt würde ich
jetzt auch vermuten weil das ist ein dankbares thema da kann man viel zeigen und vor allem
kann man immer so ganz viel machen so nach dem otto guckt mal hier und wenn ich jetzt
den button klicke dann habe ich adminrechte auf dem server oder bei adminrechte ein bisschen
schwieriger ist ja da kann man kann man viel zeigen das eignet sich gut für ein video
ok zumindest so schon mal zumindest eine sache muss man sagen schönes material die sein
sie so webseiten müssen erst mal optisch was her machen ich hoffe die lautstärke geht
das ist die abmischung ist bis sie bis sie ungleichmäßig und auf dieser seite habe
ich ehrlich gesagt einige sicherheitslücken eingebaut ja man sieht schon hier oben nicht
sicher aber aber gut dass da oben nicht sicher steht ist vielleicht programm bei der webseite
hat aber erst mal mit der webseite ja nichts zu tun was verraten wenn wir jetzt einfach
die seite sehen könnten wir hier eine datei auswählen und dann könnte ich hier etwas
hochladen aber ok solange wie das zum aufgehen brauche ist das bestimmt in der windows vm
funktioniert erst einmal nicht ja wenn ich jetzt mein profil wird oder sowas hochladen
möchte und hier auf upload image drücke dann wird die datei nicht hochgeladen denn ich
muss hier noch mein password eingeben und das verrate ich dir natürlich jetzt erst
einmal noch nicht also was kann man machen ja du könntest ein password geben das wäre
natürlich am einfachsten aber so leicht wird sie am einfachsten ist das ist das ein schwarbe
das ganz große nicht sicher oben in der browser zeile das ist natürlich schon mal ein interessanter
hinweis der sagt jetzt aber nichts über die sicherheit der programmierten webseite aus
sondern dieses nicht sicher sagt richtig erst einmal aus dass hier kein ssl zertifikat vorhanden
ist das bedeutet im umkehrschluss dass die verbindung zwischen browser und dem webserver
unverschlüsselt stattfindet was bedeutet alle sachen die hochgeladen werden die wirkliche
leute worte worte ich wollte gerade sagen wetten ich mein dieser message parameter hier oben
ja der der schreit mich auch schon der springt mich quasi direkt aus dem bildschirm an
da kommt garantiert auch noch irgendwas wird die kommunikation zwischen webserver und dem
browser hier sind unverschlüsselt und zwar ich will jetzt kein wie heißt das alters alters
schämen betreiben oder so aber wie alt sind die jungs die sind doch nicht alt oder die sind also
die sind wenn es hoch kommt 20 nicht dass man auch keine ahnung ich will nicht sagen dass man
da keine art planer fort haben kann aber die sehen äußerst äußerst jung aus angenommen wir
wären jetzt bei starbucks in einem öffentlichen netzwerk und ich würde neben dir sitzen und du
würdest dich hier einloggen dann könnte ich als hacker unter umständen dein password mitlesen
und nicht nicht wenn du mein nord vpn sponsoring mitgemacht hast was es nie gegeben hat ich sehe
hier auf diesem system wir haben das ganze schon vorbereitet wir haben hier die software wireshark
ist ein ganz wunderbares stück software wireshark in netzwerken mitzuhören was für datenpakete
ja gut man muss immer sagen ja ok ich gebe ihnen recht wenn das das wenn das irgendein
unverschlüsseltes offenes wlan ist ok ok aber das ist ja meistens nicht der fall also das
kommt sicherlich vor aber die wenigsten leute sind in einem offenen wlan drin und stimmt
wireshark auf deutsch und an anderen stellen bringt ihr das nix weil wenn wenn jetzt wenn jetzt
einer von euch daheim sitzt ja noch diesen webserver drauf geht dann müsste ich ja irgendwo in der
netzwerk infrastruktur auf dem weg sitzen oder euren switchport gemirrored haben keine ahnung
irgendwas und und euren kram mitschneiden also ja ok bei einem öffentlichen public unverschlüsselten
wlan was dann auch kein portal hat was mich auf ein verschlüsseltes umbiegt und auch keine
proxies vielleicht ok also bei einem ja bei einem bei einem offenen oder gar unverschlüsselten
wlan lasse ich mir das noch gefallen aber die meisten webservices sind ja verschlüsselt
du hast auch kaum noch was sei es jetzt google gmx web de der login 99 prozent der webseiten
die interessant sind haben ja mittlerweile also mal tls verschlüsselung da bin ich mir ehrlich
gesagt jetzt aus dem kopf gar nicht so sicher da bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher ich verich
rate jetzt mal ich bitte das habe ich mir noch nie so genau angeguckt also ich vermute mal dass
wenn du ein verschlüsseltes wlan hast mit einem pre-shared key also mit einem was du als wlan
password halt normalerweise also man nennt es pre-shared key aber eigentlich meist leute sagen
halt wlan password ja also ich denke mal du musst den hand den handshake oder die den
verbindungsaufbau mitschneiden vermute ich jetzt mal gut wenn wart ihr das auch sagt dann gehe
ich mal von aus das ist so weil wenn wir beide die gleiche idee hatten dann denke ich mal ist
da was dran also ich würde auch vermuten du musst den handshake mitschneiden aber du wirst
wahrscheinlich den kompletten traffic mitschneiden über das wlan und dann hast du den handshake mit
dabei und du hast halt auch den traffic mit dabei wie einfach das also wie einfach oder
kompliziert das dann nach ist muss ich dir ehrlich sagen keine ahnung das habe ich noch
nie ausprobiert und ja ich meine bei einem unverschlüsselten wlan keine frage ich denke
mal bei allem anderen wird noch ein bisschen mehr nötig sein dass du dir den handshake angucken
musst weil das wlan passport hast du ja dann kannst du sicherlich mit dem mitgeschnittenen handshake
irgendwie den key raus bekommen und dann mit dem key die weiteren pakete entschlüsselt rate ich
jetzt mal leute habe ich noch nie gemacht ja aber das angriffsszenario an sich ist auch schon
relativ aber so sehr spezifisch ja das war im besten nicht nur offen ist am besten sogar
komplett unverschlüsseltes wlan und dann auch einen service komplett ohne tls ja gut es ist
halt ist halt zu demonstrationszwecken ja ich wüsste jetzt nicht ob ob der skivor was mit
tls ssl zu tun hat oder nicht das kann ich dir so nicht sagen na man in the middle musste
da nix machen du kannst ja einfach alle pakete mitschneiden das ist ja das schöne an wlan das
geht ja über die luft da musst du du bist quasi immer in the middle also du musst keine klassische
man in the middle geschichte machen mit dass du jetzt beispielsweise dich als server ausgibst die
verbindung entgegen nimmst und dann an den server weiterleitest das musst du nicht machen wlan
reicht wenn du deine deine netzwerkarte in den boar wie heißt das ding noch mal genau
promis promisius mode auch grad wie heißt das war ja wo entfohlen war ja schag prom ja ja da ist das da hier der
promis ich habe keine ahnung ob das ausspricht okay leute hört zu hört zu promiske es promiske
es mode also alles klar in den promiske es promiske es mode kannst du deine netzwerkarte
schalten kannst du alles mögliche mitschneiden da müsstest halt im nachhinein bloß gucken wo
war der handshake dann irgendwie das passwort dann mit dem passwort den den schlüssel raus
bekommen an die weiteren pakete entschlüsselt aber ich wette mit euch dafür gibt schon fertige
tools die das machen habe ich mich aber noch nie großartig mit beschäftigt ja okay schauen
wir mal weiter hier werden das heißt das was wir jetzt hier sehen also was ja schon mal etwas
das ist dass das eigentlichen php ding ist ich wette ich wette das kommt kommt später noch zu
gute wenn sie irgendwie code injecten wollen oder so da kommt da kommt 100 pro was in der
rechte und auch könne ich habe ich habe sie ich habe es immer wieder es wird einfach zu gut
passen das sind alle datenpakete die jetzt hier in unserem wlan gerade hin und her geschickt
wurden richtig genau und das ist der erste mal das ist erst einmal nur alle pakete die auf
80 der filter ist aber verkehrt wahrscheinlich sind wirklich alle pakete es sind nicht alle
pakete sind die nicht schon auf die session gefiltert egal wenn schon vor einiger zeit eben
mitgehört wurde ja natürlich rekman php kann man selbst programmieren am besten ist für so
einfache sachen gar keine sachen selbst stricken sondern irgendwelche fertigen frameworks verwenden
die das halt ordentlich implementiert haben ja du dabei warst du hier einzuloggen also ich
meine ernsthaft werden auch ein php script an seinen server hinlegt und dort dann versucht
über irgendwelche wie heißt das php deine deine variablen die dir die dir in deinem post mit
geschickt kriegst da versuchst irgendwas selbst zu passen und und alles ja dann dann hast ja den
schuss mehr gehört ja dann wird dann willst du eigentlich dass dein kram nicht sicher funktioniert
aber wenn irgendwas wie lara well verwendest oder irgendwas was was taugt dann hast du ganz
viele sicherheitsprobleme wahrscheinlich erst mal gar nicht oder aber oder gleich was anderes
verwenden als php aber ganz ehrlich selbst in php kannst du gescheite sachen machen
und jetzt können wir hier einfach mal schauen also zeigt darauf sehen denn dadurch dass die
kommunikation ja da bin ich wieder ist müssten wir in der lage sein mithören zu können was hier
für passwörter verwendet wurden ok das heißt du siehst hier immer jetzt die source quasi ist immer
die ip adresse von meinem computer und gleichzeitig sehen wir auch eine destination wo das ganze
hingesendet wurde der wirkliche public web server dahingestellt mit dem ding drauf und hier steht
sogar teilweise noch so ein bisschen info an welche datei das ganze gesendet wurde richtig genau und
hier sehen wir jetzt natürlich normale tcp pakete die hin und her geschickt werden ja janes php ist
gar nicht so also php kann man kann man durchaus durchaus verwenden raw php ja also irgendwie
in irgendwas für sich index punkt php und dort dann irgendwelche sachen selbst machen das ist
das eigentliche was ich nicht machen würde php hat einen riesen vorteil heute ich hab es
schon oft genug gesagt php läuft einfach überall der letzte klitsch die letzte hauster klitsche
ja die irgendwo im billigsten rechenzentrum irgendwie noch 3 3 server stehen hat die hosting
anbieten für 50 cent im monat die haben php support also wem der vm zu teuer ist wem der
linux vm zu teuer ist um da beispielsweise irgendeine dotnet anwendung drauf laufen zu
lassen eine java anwendung eine nojs anwendung oder der auch keinen bock hat die größeren
clouddienste zu verwenden die das supporten wer wirklich irgend so nur nach 15 billig hauster
verwenden will der fährt mit php ganz gut weil php läuft einfach überall wenn jetzt irgendjemand
sagt ich will für 80 cent im monat in forum hosten dann bleibt da nur php weil php einfach
überall drauf ist und überall geht für uns jetzt sehr interessant ist ist eben htdp das
hypertext transfer protokoll das wird benutzt von webseiten und hier auch vom webserver
und da können wir uns jetzt darauf fokussieren hier sehen wir zum beispiel unser index punkt
pp falsches password was bedeutet wir haben index punkt pfp abgefragt allerdings wenn
wir formulare absenden dann ist das immer post weil wir da daten mitschicken im bodo
und wir sehen ja auch ein man kann mit einem get wie man hier sieht ja auch sachen schicken
aber in der regel ist es ein poster oder schon recht not punkt pp oder aus dem patch oder
es ist ein wie heißt das andere mal chat brain leg get post patch delete put put put meinte
ich genau putt patch verwendest du eigentlich gar nicht mehr ne putt machst du eigentlich
in der regel patch ist eigentlich outdated overrated she baited das macht eigentlich
keiner mehr prop find klingt ein bisschen nach webdav wieso machen die alles mit get requests
die schlimmste api die ich kenne hat so einen hat so einen cmdb tool bei uns auf der arbeit
jetzt jetzt ohne spaß die haben eine jason api in der muss man also die haben eine rest
api die im prinzip nur get requests kann für alles und schwachsinn die nur post requests
verwendet für fast alles also macht so sachen wie slash logout ist auch ein post request
und sowas zumindest in diesem post request musst du jason reinpacken und in diesem jason
gibt es dann so sachen wie filter fällt eins größer fünf oder sowas ja das ist so ein
cmdb tool wo halt hardware inventarisiert wird und sowas so und jetzt jetzt kommt aber
jetzt kommt der hit das ist quasi eine rest api die nicht wirklich rest ist weil die nur
post verwendet und in dem post in dem jason body für in dem post request ist embedded
xml für manche filter also du hast embedded xml in jason in dem post request sonst funktioniert
jetzt nicht also das ist wirklich eines der schlimmsten sachen die ich hier gesehen habe
embedded xml im übrigens auch eine richtig auch eine richtig ekliche api die ich letztens
gesehen habe weiß ich ob jemand mal dort domains registriert hat die sind nicht sonderlich
tolle aber ich musste letztens die die name silo api abfragen und die haben auch nur
xml leute die haben nur xml ich kann mir vor wie im letzten jahrtausend guck mal du kriegst
du kriegst alles du kriegst alles nur als get domain info du kriegst du kriegst nur
xml geschätzt zurück ich mein immerhin es ist halbwegs gut lesbares durchdachtes xml
ja das ist aus der historie nein es ist nicht es ist nicht i wo irgendjemand etop ne ich
kann euch sagen was es für ein tool ist fnt nennt sich das das tool also genauso eklig
wie die website ist das tool an sich auch informationen ok kann man guck mal wenn sogar
der cookie hinweis auf der seite schon kaputt ist dann weißt du schon was dich erwartet
bei dieser software ja der cookie hinweis ist broken vielleicht liegt es auch an mir
ah moment die haben dies wirklich geschafft dass mein dass mein ad blocker ihren cookie
hinweis block ok live demo ja die wissen schon warum sie keine screenshots drinne haben weil
das tool halt weil das tool halt wirklich hässlich wie die nacht ist zeige ich mal
ein paar screenshots ja ja so ungefähr sieht das aus ja sieht aus wie 1995 die hatten übrigens
bis vor ein paar jahren kein html frontend die hatten noch java nicht java flash also
bis vor zwei drei jahren war die war das frontend noch komplett in flash die haben jetzt erst
html 5 jetzt ihr müsst euch vorstellen vor zwei jahren war das noch flash alter ganz
schrecklich ganz schrecklich so also genauso wie das aussieht bedient sich das auch und
genauso toll bedient sich auch die api du musst halt für irgendwelche filter musst du xml
in jason in in post requests machen es ist keine elektron anwendung die funktioniert
schon im browser mittlerweile auch ohne flash ok wir gucken jetzt das video weiter eine
ganz ganz schreckliche eichs bombs was eichs bombs als allein schon der name mann eichs
bombs wie nennt warum nennt man seine software so ok es ist eitel konform eitel konform
muss schon mal dann dann dann also software die wir mit eitel konform zu sein ist in
der regel auch automatisch kacke zu bedienen eichs bombs oh das sieht auch schon ziemlich
aus wie 1995 aber auf so einen scheiß stehen doch eigentlich nur irgendwelche management
leute oder die hübsche grafen von den server umgebungen haben beziehungsweise von vom rechen
zentrum oder so haben wollen aber eigentlich gar keine ahnung ich weiß nicht keine ahnung
egal wir schauen jetzt mal das video weiter sonst werden wir nie fertig
der name ist schon sehr sus ja also dass das dafür wahrscheinlich hätte ich mir auch
gedacht nur mit password angesprochen werden kann übrigens wir müssen in einem der nächsten
streams leute ich habe mir ein schönes kleines bastelprojekt von stream überlegt wir gucken
uns mal avalonia an demnächst ein cross platform gui framework für dotnet wollte ich mir schon
eine weile angucken und wir bauen eine desktop suche aber leute nix was wirklich gut wird
und man am ende verwenden kann ich baue einfach ich mache eine liste mit dateinamen und filter
die dann über übers frontend aber ich habe mir überlegt avalonia ui wäre wirklich mal
eine coole sache weil ich bin lange ich bin schon lange auf der suche nach irgendwas was
man cross platform desktop gui technisch verwenden kann was halt nicht qc plus plus ist und was
nicht elektron ist ja genau genau so was in der richtung kriegst ein suchfeld wir machen
vielleicht war mein index vielleicht machen wir sogar einen index also entweder entweder
machen wir den index mit sq lite kann man index mit datein machen oder wir machen lucy
in dotnet habe ich noch nie verwendet keine ahnung wie gut man so was verwenden kann könnten
auch wir könnten auch rust verwenden und interop mit sie scharf machen oder so ganz abgedreht
das zeug mal schauen
sq lite bin ich mir selbst nicht so sicher also sq lite kann ja volltext suche ganz
brauchbar sq lite kann auch mittlerweile experimentell sprich man das spricht man das auf deutsch
aus trichram trichram indexe also dass du substrings suchen kannst leider kann enter
die framework core diese ganzen sachen nicht da müssen wir halt raw sql querys selbst
machen ja genau genau ich erkläre euch jetzt mal was passt mal auf ich erkläre euch jetzt
mal kurz was 5 hat 5 hat time 5 hat time also vielen ich muss mal ein bisschen musik anmachen
ja wollte ich dachte ich mir dass es jemand fragen will also passt mal auf ich erkläre
euch das jetzt mal ganz kurz aber nur ganz kurz also
what the fuck wo ist denn jetzt die seite also so sachen wie sq lite oder postgres
oder elastic search oder so was die bieten ja die möglichkeit dass du ganz ganz viel
text indizierst und dann den index durch suchst nach bestimmten wörtern also du hast
beispielsweise die komplette wikipedia die lässt du indizieren und dann kannst du beispielsweise
sagen ja aus dem index kannst du dann relativ schnell raussuchen ja ich hätte gerne alle
artikel die das wort sebaro enthalten und dann geht es relativ schnell weil das eben
schon indiziert ist müssen jetzt nicht so sehr ins detail gehen das ist ein inverted
index wo dann können wir uns vielleicht bei bei gelegenheit mal angucken aber ein nachteil
ist und ich erkläre das jetzt nur es ist eine art hash funktion nee es ist keine hash
funktion es ist ein inverted index also du speicherst dir worter ab das ist halt die
frage wie du das indizierst in der regel in der regel nimmst du worter in der regel
splittest du den input in worter also das hier und das hier das hier also du du du
tauchen heißt nennt sich das dann also du du splittest den input in häppchen in der
regel sind es worter da gibt es ganz ganz viele richtig fife hat funktion ja die machen
dann aus wortern die dann ähnlich sind das gleiche base wort und so was aber in der regel
splittest du so ein input text in worter und für diese worter speicherst du dann in welchem
dokument sie an welcher stelle auftauchen und dann musst du nur deinen index durchsuchen
wenn du nach einem wort suchst und dann bekommst automatisch weil das ja ein inverted index
also du sagst nicht etwa die artikel sondern du machst das umgedreht du splittest das
in worter und dann kannst du in einem index nachgucken ok dieses wort kommt im dokument
xy vor an position fünf so das ist das was in der regel ftr full text search macht schreie
ich ist das so laut wollte ich wollte ich gar nicht also das ist in der regel das was
full text search macht ganz ganz ganz einfach gesagt der nachteil ist der nachteil ist du
kannst keine substring suchen normalerweise weil du indizierst ja nur worter du indizierst
fts 5 is an sq light virtual table module that provides so und wenn du jetzt sagen möchtest
gibt mir mal alle dokumenten die ovidis enthalten da geht das nicht so ohne weiteres weil dein
index eben aus ganzen wortern besteht was du jetzt machen kannst ist du kannst deinen
kompletten index scannen von anfang bis ende und das dauert halt eine weile deswegen können
übrigens suchmaschinen in der regel auch kein wildcard am anfang also falls ich euch
schon mal gefragt habe warum können suchmaschinen in der regel keine wildcards also sprich warum
können suchmaschinen sowas hier nicht dann liegt das genau daran die indizieren die
worter und wenn du nicht den anfang vom wort weißt weißt du nicht wo du im index gucken
musst du kannst da nur den ganzen index durchscannen also so was können suchmaschinen wieder in
der regel weil du zumindest am anfang vom index weißt wo du anfangen musst und bist
deutlich schneller als den kompletten index zu scannen deswegen wildcard am anfang geht
in der regel nicht so was du jetzt machen kannst ist wenn du auch substrings matchen
möchtest also wenn du zum beispiel sagen möchtest ich will jetzt nicht nur suchen
können welche dokumenten enthalten das wort provides übrigens da ist richtig viel gehirn
schmalz dahinter also sprich wenn du einen ordentlichen token oder ordentliches ordentliches
volltext suche programm hast der macht dann aus provides und provide und providing macht
er das gleiche base wort und indiziert nur das ja dass es dann besser findet so aber
wenn jetzt zum beispiel auch suchen können willst nach allen dokumenten die ovidis enthalten
dann musst du dir überlegen wie schaffe ich das im index aufzubauen der auch teile
der worte enthält und das machst du in der regel mit einem trikram tokenizer also anstatt
dass du jetzt worter die einzelnen worter für deinen index nimmst nimmst du dreier
paare von den wortern also immer drei dreier buchstaben paare also aus output wird o u
t ut p t pu put ut und t also das indiziert quasi in dreier häppchen immer von anfang
bis ende über das wort drüber und dann hast du ein index der ist deutlich größer am ende
weil anstatt dass du output einmal in deinem index speichert musst du halt für output
quasi das komplette wort splitting in dreier häppchen warum genau drei drei ist ganz einfach
weil du damit feststellen kannst was da vorne nachkommt du kannst auch du kannst du kannst
auch zweier nehmen du musst immer so ein bisschen in kompromiss du kannst auch einser nehmen
das muss immer so ein bisschen kompromiss sein aus größe größe und ähm geschwindigkeit
ja also du kannst auch immer einzelne buchstaben nehmen dann wird dein index halt wahrscheinlich
ziemlich groß und der vorteil von dreiern ist du kannst relativ einfach äh checken
was danach kommt ja also sprich du kannst dann gucken hier take und dann nimmst du das
nächste und sagst dann aha du nimmst was das mit k anfängt dann weißt du das kommt
dann hinten dran ja es ist trade off und weil du weil du für substring matchings sind
drei ziemlich ziemlich gut so guck und dann kann man hier sowas machen wenn man das nämlich
trigram tokenized dann kann man sagen hier select form bla bla bla bla bla und dann erkennt
er das auch aha es ist ein substring von also hij ist ein substring von abcdefg hij so gut
lange rede kurzer sinn sehr sehr oft hoppig jetzt gewesen aber das ist eine der varianten
wie man seine volltext suche substring match fähig macht was man ja unter anderem braucht
wenn man da teilnahmen indiziert weil da teilnahmen ist ja willst du substring matchen können
da teilnahmen ist ja dann quasi sowas wie keine wah slash user slash keckel slash plupp
punkt waff so wenn du das wenn du das matchen willst da bringt ihr splitten an leerzeichen
nix und splitten an slash ist auch nicht wirklich weil du willst vielleicht du willst vielleicht
wirklich nur nach plupp suchen oder nur oder nur oder nur nach blu und willst trotzdem
das da matchen ja so komplett oft topic jetzt gewesen jetzt gucken wir jetzt gucken wir
das video weiter aber chat eins muss man sagen bildungsauftrag erfüllt oder jetzt hat man
jetzt hat man wieder was gelernt schauen wir schauen wir uns weiter wie der webserver gehackerment
wird hier drin unser password ja du hast recht es ist im prinzip kannst du es auch mit zwei
machen das ist deswegen 3 kram sind halt drei in der regel diese technik nennt sich n kram
das könnte ja quasi auch eins bis fünf sein oder so also achso nehme zwei index ja das
kannst du auch machen das funktioniert aber auch nicht für unterschiedliche wörter
du kannst die wörter vorwärts und rückwärts speichern das hat den vorteil du kannst anfangen
du kannst hinten anfangen zu suchen aber substring matchen bringt es dir trotzdem nicht so weiter
gucken wir fertig so jetzt lesen wir hier mal durch das sieht man jetzt natürlich viele
informationen also welcher port benutzt wurde zu welchem port wir hin wollen port 80 das
ist der standard htp port der unverschüssete sei dazu gesagt der unverschüsset ist der
nur ist ist er nicht unbedingt kommt drauf an was dahinter ist aber ja in der regel schon
der htps port man kann auch man kann auch wenn man das auch wenn man das in regeln
man kann auch htps über port 80 machen man kann auch htp über port 443 machen was ziemlich
kontraproduktiv ist und eigentlich alle nur verwirrt aber man könnte es machen hier drei
und wir sehen hier oben auch den host also wohin verbunden wurde und das ist eben genau
die domain die wir hier auch in unserem test set up haben wir können hier durchschauen
take wir gerade bin ich freue ich mich ja ja informationen die wurde hier in diesem
daten flow drin sind die meistens hat es den header interessant wir sehen hier gibt
ihr header also was für daten hochgeladen wurden da gibt es auch verschiedene
verschiedene möglichkeiten user agent das hier mozilla wohl in diesem system verwendet
das ist der das ist der standard user agent der mittlerweile von allen browsers mitgeschickt
wird weil du mittlerweile am browser user agent gar nicht mehr erkennen können sollst was du
für einen browser verwendest aber es gibt trotzdem tricks und wege trotzdem das raus zu bekommen
also also man hat es abgeschafft dass man über den user agent den browser identifizieren kann
aber es gibt trotzdem möglichkeiten den user agent zu identifizieren also eigentlich hätte
man sich sparen können stehen viele informationen drin aber vielleicht finden wir ja auch unser
password hier irgendwo in der ganzen geschichte wir sind nämlich hier jetzt aber ist es denn
da daten drin wo ist das password und wir haben hier guck mal da das formular fehlt password und
das klingt mir jetzt persönlich sehr danach wie wenn hier das password enthalten wäre okay
leute wer ist feifert ascii 54 ascii 54 ist ah ne ascii ich glaube 60 oder 63 ist ascii
ah ok ascii ascii 54 exzellent zeigt mal her ach so ist das hex oder ist das dezimal keine ahnung
also 54 wäre dann 6 oder aber t wenn es hex ist
wahrscheinlich ist es hex also ist das erste zeichen ein t
oder aber es ist dezimal und dann ist das erste zeichen eine 6 ne doch
wahrscheinlich ist es sechs leute wieviel sind das wieviel wieviel zeichen sind das sieben
ne
aber bei beiden längst sieben ja so ich hätte gesagt 6 6 5 4 3 2 1 0 oder so was wahrscheinlich
wir haben auch die daten des passwords und wir haben hier natürlich die daten das sind jetzt
viele zahlen es könnte es natürlich das password sein vielleicht hat hier niemand nur zahlen
als password benutzt was ich nicht empfehle jeder patrick hat recht unsicher sieben bytes und so
viel data das muss hex sein allerdings ist es in dem fall so dass das hier als hex verschlüsselt
ist das hex mit 0x anfängt ist ja rein eine so eine eine convention dass man in deinem source
code weiß was gemeint ist das muss in wire shark ja nicht unbedingt zu sein ich weiß es
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht ob das wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich ist es hex ja wieder fit
ja geht so hex ist oder verschlüsselt ist eigentlich komplett der falsche begriff es
ist eigentlich nur eine inkodierung das heißt wir müssen hier jetzt nichts entschlüsseln
sondern wir müssen das ganze nur dekodieren und da gibt es verschiedene tools die mal
allerdings ist hier das erste ist hier relativ angenehm und das erste ist mit in wire shark
die das ganze möglich machen würde ich das ganze hier gerne an achte ich helfe dir einfach mal
kannst du jetzt einfach rechts klicken richtig es ist ein wenig pence gem wire shark auf deutsch
zu sehen muss ich ehrlich sagen weiß nicht wie es euch geht aber ich finde das äußerst
gewöhnungsbedürftig und dann können wir tatsächlich das ganze einfach kopieren und
wir können das als hex kopieren dann haben wir hier unsere zahlenkette oder wir können
das ganze einfach als druckbaren text kopieren druckbaren als druckbaren text ok das heißt
wahrscheinlich auf englisch auch nicht anders aber wire shark auf deutsch common bruh die
konversion von hier einmal diese hex zahlenkette hin zu unserem lesbaren password und wenn wir
das ganze jetzt einfügen dann test 123 und jetzt können wir natürlich dateien hochladen aber
das war es wir wollen aber noch einen schritt weitergehen und unter umständen auch die kontrolle
über das system übernehmen das wäre natürlich der check ok ok ich predicte einfach mal was
jetzt kommt in diesem message in diesem message falsches password da injecten die jetzt irgendwas
oder so und weil sphp ist und sie einfach absolut gar nichts es kämpfen wird das dann auf dem
server ausgeführt oder irgendwie sowas in der richtung und das könnten wir jetzt mal ausprobieren
dass eben war noch mein test password was ich hier eingegeben habe aber das heißt wir könnten jetzt
hier oben einfach mal die aufzeichnung stoppen und einfach mal neue aufzeichnung starten und
dann einfach warten bis irgendjemand sein password man muss aber dazu sagen jetzt muss ich jetzt
mal sagen an der stelle also das ist das ist ein sehr unwahrscheinliches angriffsszenario was wir
hier sehen ich meine okay in dem fall man ist tatsächlich in einem unverschlüsselten wlan und
man gibt sein password auf irgendeinem webserver lokal ein der kein tls hat okay das ist aber ein
eher so ein eher theoretischer fall also praktisch wird das wenig wenig vorkommen gerade bei wichtigen
diensten ist das egal du findest heute kaum was log in technisch ohne ttps ohne tls ja sei es
irgendwie die gmx emails web de emails google youtube mein wegen facebook instagram egal was
also das hat eigentlich alles ist es eigentlich alles verschlüsselt und dann dann bringt sie im
endeffekt auch nichts ob das wlan offen ist und es mitschneiden kannst ja da kannst du zwar im
klartext sehen was verschickt wird aber also w auf wlan seite aber unten drunter ist es
trotzdem verschlüsselt ende zu ende und insofern naja was heißt es käpen näher was dass du nicht
die sachen eins zu eins zu nimmst wie sie reinkommen sondern dass du erste mal das wie
wie könnte man wie könnte man das auf deutsch wie könnte man das auf deutsch denn was heißt
denn moment was was heißt es auf deutsch dass du es des infizierst also du des infizierst
es erst mal du sorgst einfach dafür dass beispielsweise ich mir fällt das schwierig
das auf deutsch zu sagen du sorgst zum beispiel dafür dass spezielle zeichen die normalerweise
sorgstechnisch was bedeuten würden eben so umgeschrieben werden dass sie eben nichts
mehr machen ja also zum beispiel zum beispiel einer der klassiker einer der klassiker ist
ja sowas hier zum beispiel ja drop table keckel oder sowas so das wäre so eines eines der
klassiker eines der klassiker schlechthin und damit das nicht funktioniert ist das beste
wenn du irgendeinen input bekommst erst mal dafür zu sorgen warum stehen da irgendwelche
komischen und es kämpten sachen drinnen ja und dann würdest du dann wahrscheinlich
hier sowas draus machen und was auch immer so noch besser ist es natürlich noch besser
ist es natürlich wenn du die sachen nicht nur einfach es kämpft bevor du sie verarbeitest
sondern wenn du sachen die du vom user bekommst erst gar nicht an der stelle in deinem programm
verwendest wo es quasi direkt evaluiert ausgeführt interpretiert wird also in der regel solltest
du user input nie nehmen und in irgendwo reinhauen wo direkt eins zu eins der text verwendet
wird also du willst du willst in der regel kein lese input und dann execute das als
source code machen also du musst dich auch wenn du musst dich auch wenn ein ordentliches
framework verwendest teilweise schon ziemlich fragwürdig anstellen dass dir der fehler
überhaupt noch passieren kann ich meine in dem fall haben sie es wahrscheinlich absichtlich
so gemacht dass man das beispiel hier gut zeigen kann aber versuch mal beispielsweise
eine sag mal eine asp.net core anwendung zu machen machen ein parameter rein in den string
und versucht dort dich mal irgendwie zu injecten lassen das geht gar nicht so ohne weiteres
das einzige was mir einfallen würde was du warst du mit ganz ganz viel nicht nachdenken
hinbekommen könntest ist wenn du tatsächlich der meinung bist du musst in den datenbank
query machen und du verwendest dafür nicht strikt das was entity framework dir bereitstellt
sondern du machst irgendwelche raw sql queries in deinem controller und in dieses raw sql
query setzt du dann quasi das ein was du als parameter bekommen hast aber das macht keiner
der noch irgendwie bei verstand ist und also wer das macht normalerweise sage ich ja du
kannst nichts dafür wenn du missed programmierst ja also ich kann keiner rausschmeißen wenn
du missed programmiert hast aber das wäre schon ein fall wo ich sagen würde hey also
ein raw sql query machen an der stelle wo du kein raw sql query machen musst und dort
dann auch noch eins zu eins den user input reinschreiben also das ist schon ja also
das ist ungefähr wie was weiß ich wenn der klempner die sicherung falsch rum rein macht
oder nicht die sicherung die dichtung falsch rum rein macht und dann hast du einen wasserschaden
im keller oder so naja egal weiter richtig stripes dangesche für den sub ja ich glaube
wir brauchen jetzt läuft da genau hat einen kleinen moment gedauert und ich gebe jetzt
hier mal als dummer nutzer mein password ja das sehen sie jetzt im wireshark das ist
uns auch klar und weder mir eine datei aus natürlich erst mal einfach mein guck mal
leute guck mal leute kein padding im input text weird champ eine datei aus natürlich
erst mal einfach mein logo hier schon so eine gefährliche was ist das was sehe ich
denn hier ich ahne schlimmes leute ich ahne schlimmes datei die hier vorbereitet wurde
ignorieren wir einfach ich lade jetzt erst einmal etwas hoch und wir sehen auch hier
screenshot wurde hochgeladen das ganze scheint zu klappen ja dann schauen wir doch mal drauf
können wir auf die datei überhaupt zugreifen da können wir garantiert zugreifen den ich
mal von meinem code gemacht habe und das öffnet sich ja auch direkt wenn man drauf drückt
hier sehen wir jetzt auch jede menge verbindungen eigentlich nur hier das hier wahrscheinlich
herausfinden genau dass wir jetzt wieder hier die gleiche ablaufpunkt per p-datei wir sehen
wieder unsere index per p-datei und natürlich die ganzen das password und hier können 55 ok
wir wissen dass 54 t ist heute 55 ist ein was u oder die hex jetzt wieder kopieren also
wir haben hier wieder unseren hex da müssen wir jetzt noch rein zu den daten dann können
wir auf kopieren und dann wir können es jetzt wieder als hex der ausdruckbare der druckbare
text wäre ganz angenehm ich muss mir nachher marken wie das in feier schalke normal heißt
eine neue zeile und fügen das password und was ist es hoffentlich ein hochsicheres password
aber mit u war man schon mal richtig kreativ ganz wunderbar ja dann schauen wir wieder
zurück könnten wir ein bild hochladen direkt da drauf gedrückt wir müssen zuerst die datei
auswählen so jetzt können wir natürlich das test png mal ausprobieren öffnen das password
eingeben falls du so nett wärst und dann genau ist es eingegeben aber upload image wunderbar
also diese message da oben ja da muss noch was kommen mit die springt mich einfach zu
sehr an jetzt können wir die dateien hochladen und ich gehe jetzt mal davon aus ich weiß
ja nicht wie der program code aussieht ich hoffe jetzt mal dass nur bilder hochgeladen
werden können denn falls wir ausführbaren code hochladen können und der ausführbare
code von außen zugänglich ist können wir nach belieben also zwischen zwischen hochladen
und ausführen sind ja noch zwei verschiedene paar schuhe also wenn ich da einfach der text
datei hochladen kann mit der endung php das ist zwar nicht schön aber das ist noch nicht
schlimm wenn das ding natürlich die php datei einfach mal ausführt dann ist das ich wüsste
gar nicht wie man das hinbekommen kann dass das wie macht man das eigentlich dass es
überhaupt geht alles hochladen was wir wollen und auf dem system ausführen was im endeffekt
bedeutet die kontrolle über das system zu übernehmen und das wurde jetzt noch nicht
getestet das probieren wir jetzt hier live zusammen mit euch aus wir haben ja schon diese
verdächtige shell.php die du gerade mit mir zusammen rausgesucht hast vor dem video die
jetzt jetzt hoch genau das ist einfach relativ also das gar nichts kompliziertes das ist
von von github tatsächlich und was hier jetzt passiert ist dass wir den ausführbaren code
hochladen und der ausführbare code dann auf unsere kommandos warten sollte und die dann
an das system weitergeben sollte wir haben jetzt hier das schöne password wir haben die
datei wir laden das mal hoch und so wie es aussieht haben wir überhaupt keine filter
drin weder hier im frontend noch im backend bei gut wenn da filter drin bei mir gibt es
das video nicht ist es so dass hier im frontend dann nur jpegs oder pngs ausgewählt werden
können im backend aber mehr erlaubt ist dann kann man den request abfangen kann den request
modifizieren und dann weiter senden also dass man im frontend vorgaukelt man würde ein
bild hochladen und dann im nachhinein bevor der request an den server geht bearbeitet
das was anderes hochgeladen wurde das brauchen wir jetzt nicht sondern wir können jetzt
direkt probieren kommen wir auf die schelpunkt pp drauf also und es sieht sehr gut aus warum
führt er den kram überhaupt aus das eigenen pp ding oder was ich überlege ernsthaft wie
ich das in irgendeiner anderen mit irgendeinem anderen framework oder mit irgendeiner anderen
programmiersprache irgendwie ähnlich überhaupt hin bekomme also für sp dot net core fällt
mir nichts ein wie ich das hinbekommen würde ja das muss das muss wahrscheinlich die kombination
sein aus web server der den request annimmt guckt ob es eine datei gibt die so heißt
und die dann einfach ungefragt ausführt ja das ist halt doof dass der web server keine
ahnung hat was eigentlich zur anwendung gehört und was nicht
ja und warum kann man überhaupt warum kann man überhaupt upload warum ist überhaupt
uploads aufrufbar also warum führt er überhaupt sachen in uploads aus na gut es ist es ist
halt wahrscheinlich pp standard standard settings ja aber ganz aufmerksam also mir würde jetzt
nix einfallen wie ich das wie ich das beispielsweise in dot net machen würde dass das überhaupt
geht mit node wird es wahrscheinlich funktionieren wenn ich dort in aber selbst aber selbst
node führt doch nicht einfach random javascript dinger aus wenn ich die wenn ich die öffne
das ist das ist auf jeden fall sehr fragwürdig konfiguriert der web server
das ist schon also schon ja keine ahnung jetzt können wir hier verschiedene befehle ausführen
probieren wir das ganze mal aus gehen auf execute und schauen was also ganz im ernst
ich hätte keine ahnung also mal genommen ich würde dort netwebanwendung machen ich
hätte absolut keine ahnung wie ich diesen fall überhaupt so bauen könnte dass es betroffen
wäre ich überlege gerade wie ich das wie ich das machen sollte mir fällt wirklich
nix ein also also mir fehlen die skills diese sicherheitslücke einzubauen ich weiß wirklich
nicht wie sie eine normale dort nennen wenn du rein bekommen würde keine ahnung das geht
wahrscheinlich nur bei sachen wo du zwei wo du ein webserver hast und dann falls die also
der webserver muss den request annehmen dann gucken ob es eine datei gibt und die dann
quasi in den interpreter weiter schieben wenn du beispielsweise dort net anwendung hast
die ja quasi webserver und anwendung in einem ist mir fällt beim besten willen nicht ein
wie ich das wie ich diese sicherheitslücke fabrizieren können sollte also ich wüsste
wirklich nicht selbst wenn einer zu mir sagt max baumann dort net anwendung die diese sicherheitslücke
hat ich wüsste nicht wie ich es machen sollte keine ahnung ich wüsste nicht wie ich es
einbauen sollte also das höchste der gefühle ist in in irgendeinem controller ohne eskäpten
ohne eskäpten input und dort und da irgendwie ein raw sql query oder so aber selbst das
wer macht denn so was der noch halbwegs bei verstand ist ja das ist wahrscheinlich wirklich
in der pap beziehungsweise script problematik zwischen webserver und dann weiter schieben
man das eigentliche programm was das ausführt aber würde man das normalerweise nicht so
machen dass du ein upload verzeichnis ok das upload verzeichnis brauchst du ja wenn du
direkt über den webserver deine bilder da drin aus auf auslesen aber du kannst doch
garantiert sei es in deiner engine x konfig oder in deiner apache konfig oder was auch
immer dem garantiert sagen dass du das nicht im upload verzeichnis machen willst dein cgi
krempel weiß ich jetzt aus dem kopf nicht wie man das wie man das einstellt aber oder
aber man würde das überhaupt nicht unterhalt machen sondern würde das parallel machen
oder kannst auf den webserver halt so konfigurieren dass es nur ja das wäre wahrscheinlich das
erste was ich machen würde ja ja gut ich meine es ist schon sehr gestellt das video
aber gut wer ist das nicht gibt es das video nicht der nutzer ww minus data das ganz wunderbar
ok das heißt du kannst jetzt einfach beliebige sachen da eingeben das heißt du kannst gerade
ls also es sind beliebige sachen der kann wenn er gatschi buss eingibt passiert nichts
befehle die man halt oder bestbefehle und da gibt es pap ist immer noch ziemlich beliebt
zum beispiel ls ein was mit die auch zurecht pap ist ja gar nicht so schlimm jetzt siehst
du alles richtig genau und jetzt kann man befehle ausführen und angenommen dass wir
jetzt tatsächlich ein projekt an dem also das erste das erste was ist das erste wer
ich jetzt machen würde erstmal ssh ich würde ich würde ich würde irgendwo ssh verbindung
aufmachen am besten auch mit einem reverse tun also mit einem mit einem mit einem port
forwarding und dann direkt da drauf und gut ist naja su wird nicht funktionieren su wird
wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren also ww data also wenn ww data jetzt auch noch sudo
machen darf dann beiß ich mir in arsch also das kannst du ja das das würde dann wirklich
auf keine kuhhaut mehr gehen dass das einer so konfiguriert du kannst auch im prinzip
irgendwas x beliebiges hochladen dann wäre jetzt natürlich nur der erste schritt getan
weil jetzt sind wir der nutzer des web servers also im grunde greifen wir auf das system
als der webserver läuft auf port 80 aber der webserver hat kein keine root rechte mehr
die machen das ja in der regel so früher hat man das gesehen in den in den in its crypts
manchmal heute ist das glaube ich bei den system d sachen nicht mehr so sichtbar in
der regel ist das ja so du startest den webserver als root aber der droppt ja komplett sein
eine rechte nachdem er seine ports aufgemacht hat also du brauchst zwar die rechte für
port 80 aber danach läuft er als ww root also da hast du eigentlich keine chance
der webserver zu der webserver hat natürlich nur beschränkte berechtigungen und der nächste
schritt wäre jetzt dass man versucht diese berechtigung zu erweitern um dann als regulärer
benutze oder im besten fall als root benutze das ganze system übernehmen zu können root
hat doch bestimmt auch passport test 123 oder so hier auf das system so zugreifen zu können
um befehle auszuführen ist natürlich schon mal ein großer erfolg ja was kannst du denn
damit zu machen wenn du jetzt wenn du das so hast kannst du theoretisch gleich dein ssh
login auf die webseite publik schreiben und sagt hallo russische china chinesen hacker
loggt euch auf meinem system ein also man kann die datei natürlich löschen man kann
noch andere software hochladen man könnte den also ich bleibe mal das programmiert doch
niemand so das musste doch wirklich schon absichtlich kaputt machen als botnet command
in control server benutzen man könnte software hochladen die wo dann didos angriffe durchführt
oder ähnliches also im grunde können wir jetzt im rahmen des webservers alles hochladen
was wir wollen wir könnten auch die die webseite verändern wir können hier du musst bei er
arbeiten jetzt hier nur im upload directory ist jetzt hier nur im ablauts directory aber
wir könnten jetzt auch auf andere directories auch mal formula befehle ausführen aber ansonsten
könnte man jetzt hier eigentlich schritt für schritt den gesamten server übernehmen ich
könnte jetzt dateien verändern ich könnte jetzt einfach keine art können wir hier jetzt
noch mal zurückgehen scheint wird das ganze hier über den ul parameter weiter ja da muss
ja noch was kommen ich sag doch diese diese message dieser parameter springt mich von
anfang an springt springt er mich schon an da muss doch jetzt noch was kommen und eventuell
können wir hier verschiedene sachen manipulieren also hat immer code einfügen javascript einfügen
und dann könnten wir diesen link an jemanden senden und falls dieser link dann hier geöffnet
wird könnten wir mit einer website die uns unter umständen gar nicht gehört sachen ausführen
angenommen das wäre jetzt hier tatsächlich eine bank website und wir könnten hier in
den link direkt reinschreiben ja sobald der link aufgemacht wird dann schick uns mal schick
uns mal geld das wäre natürlich unpraktisch wir können jetzt ja einfach mal ausprobieren
ob das ganze tatsächlich funktionieren würde also genau ja gut ja das wird wahrscheinlich
funktionieren wunderbar das ist aber gar nicht so schlimm das ist aber gar nicht so
schlimm ich meine das ist ja noch noch alles noch alles kleinzeitig das kann schlimm werden
wenn du so sachen beispielsweise eine fritz an der fritz box weiter schicken kannst gab
es ja auch schon probleme irgendwelche kleinzeit injection sachen für die fritz box die dann
wiederum dazu veranlasst wurde irgendwelche sachen zu machen ja aber das hält das das
das ist ja noch nicht ganz so schlimm das sieht nicht gut aus richtig das sieht nicht
gut aus zum beispiel wenn dann ein ries geklaut deswegen gibt es hier auch bei der developer
academy hilfe und verschiedene kurse was IT Sicherheit angeht dass man da einfach ein
grundverständnis erhält und ich würde wirklich jeden also ich hoffe keinen den sie irgendwie
an public web services ranlassen fabriziert sowas ich meine klar irgendwo muss es passieren
das kommt nicht von ungefähr die ganzen probleme die wir die letzten jahre über hatten aber
also das ist ja schon wirklich so grob fahrlässig also da muss ja an so vielen stellen scheiße
gebaut worden sein also die leute das programmieren müssen keine ahnung haben davon was sie da
programmieren die leute die den server administrieren müssen absolut keine ahnung davon haben was
sie machen also ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht also das war jetzt schon relativ gestellt
für das video ja man klar sonst gibt es das video nicht aber ich halte es immer noch für
kein allzu realistisches angriffsszenario zumal diese ganze wire shark geschichte in
der regel ja gar nichts bringt ja ok vielleicht im unverschlüsselten öffentlichen wlan mitten
im server ohne hatte tps aber normalerweise willst du die sachen ja müsstest du die sachen
ja abgreifen ohne dass du im gleichen netzwerk bist wieder wieder user und dann egal ob tls
oder nicht du kommst halt einfach an den traffic nicht dran das sei denn du hockst
im d6 am switch was die meisten wahrscheinlich nicht machen werden außer man ist das cia
oder so so was gucken wir uns als nächstes an
erst mal bisschen musik anmachen html lernen wie was das für ein was willst du mir sagen
klausi reaper design sache ich für den sub poc subscriptions hier leute sorry an alle die
ich übersehen habe das re fs video sei ganz gut aus das da new files ist im minders re
fs das ist doch schon gibt es doch schon eine ganze weile oder spuk spuk spuk musik zu zu
nerven aufräumt viel besser da gab es ein video html lernen na komm leute wir sind doch
hier mittlerweile die krassesten frontend defs die es gibt vor allem der serious max
ich glaube das ist wirklich der einzige ne das stimmt nicht der einzige aber einer der
guten frontend defs die wir hier haben wir haben hier einige schlaue leute wir haben
den auskenn fuchs der auskenn fuchs ist auch immer am start mit seinen krit layouts die
ich nicht checke wie sie funktionieren aber wo er immer weiß wie die wie die aussehen
müssen und also wir haben schon wir haben schon feifeleute im chat leute da kann man
nichts sagen hast du erfahrung mit express mit express nicht wirklich mit postcards habe
ich erfahrungen mit postcards habe ich erfahrungen mit express nicht wirklich ich hab bisher
immer einen relativ großen bogen um node.js backends gemacht ich hab das auch ehrlich
gesagt vor weiterhin einen großen bogen zu machen um node backends aber postcards ist
die beste datenbank die du verwenden kannst also ganz im ernst es gibt so viele alternativen
mittlerweile oder so viele datenbanken ja du hast so hast sachen bekanntere sachen sowas
wie mongo db im no sql bereich du hast sowas wie kasandra db wenn du irgendwelche sachen
klassen willst es gibt ja mittlerweile heute datenbanken wie sand am meer alle alle mit
ihren vornacht teilen aber ich ich sage jetzt einfach mal was in 99 oder vielleicht in 95
prozent erfällen fahrt ihr mit postcards am besten weil postcards einfach alles kann was
man braucht alles also also alles was man normalerweise so so braucht und brauchen könnte
postcards kann die ganze 0815 relationale datenbank geschichte mit sql abfrage und
sonst was postcards hat ein an eine volltext suche eine volltext suche mit substrings verschiedene
index typen für volltext suche jason support und theoretisch quasi auch so eine art no
sql support damit also postcards kann einfach alles und in der regel fährt man mit postcards
einfach am besten wenn man nicht genau spezifische anforderungen hat was man sagt nee in dem
einen fall nicht fährst du einfach mit dem gesamtpaket aus postcresti postcresti am besten
gute frage oracle ist das beste wenn du viel geld hast und wie geld ausgeben willst ansonsten
insgesamt von den features her würde ich sagen ganz ehrlich ich habe noch nie oracle
in meinem projekt umfeld verwendet wir haben auf der arbeit oracle und das ist schweine
teuer und es lässt sich nicht wird richtig virtualisieren weil du die host cpu course
bezahlen musst anstatt die vm cpu course und so was richtig richtig ja dreck in der
beziehung oracle das kann sein dass im enterprise umfeld vielleicht irgendwelche unschlagbaren
geilen features hat dass man das haben möchte da kann ich jetzt wenig zu wenig zu sagen aber
zu allem was ich bisher gemacht habe finde ich postcrest ist so als basis wenn man keine
ahnung hat was man eigentlich genau alles speichern will und was man eigentlich in zukunft
noch genau machen will fährst du eigentlich mit postcrest in der regel am besten du hast
alles in postcrest was es so gibt von volltextsuche bis jason support alles was du dir so von
dem relationalen datenbanksystem vorstellen kannst du kannst time series daten mittlerweile
speichern alles also es gibt eigentlich nix in postcrest was du nicht machen kannst klar
wenn du jetzt sag mal wenn du postcrest als no sql verwendest oder nur um da jason rein
und raus zu dampen würdest du vielleicht mit was anderem besser fahren wenn du jetzt
beispielsweise nur volltextsuche machen willst würdest du vielleicht mit was anderem besser
fahren aber wenn du was brauchst was eben eine datenbank ist und du brauchst vielleicht
noch volltextsuche dabei das ist einfach unschlagbar was postcrest für features out
of the box mitbringt
ja du kannst es gibt auch es gibt auch ein craftql aufsatz für postcrest dann hast du
quasi postcrest runter und craftql oben drüber und musst dich gar nicht mehr mit datenbank
zeug auseinandersetzen kannst nur reines frontend gedünst machen macfly danke für den sub
so was können wir uns als nächstes angucken fünf geniale tools die du kennen musst ok
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt das fünf tools die ich für meine arbeit als softwareentwickler
fast täglich verwende ich habe ok weg wir sind einfach wir sind einfach mal so frei
und klicken das schnell durch postman kann ich auch nur empfehlen poc auch auch wenn
ich immer noch so der karl der karl nennt man das so der karl boomer bin weil mir irgendwie
so ein karl oftmals einfacher von der hand geht wie postman auf einer postman ist wirklich
nice wenn man apis testen will sei es seine eigenen sei es andere ist postman postman ist
richtig gut so charles proxy das kenne ich nicht die sah wirklich vor sieben jahren noch
genau gleich was ist was ist charles proxy charles proxy ist ein htp proxy was bedeutet
dass der gesamte traffic den deine maschine oder dein smartphone das bekommen wir gleich
noch dazu mit dem internet hat kann man alles überwachen und manipulieren das heißt man
kann request faken blockieren die responses manipulieren oder einfach nur in den ganzen
datenverkehr reinschauen das geht sowohl auf dem laptop oder computer auf dem charles
installiert ist ok kann ich mir vorstellen ist praktisch mit ios und android ist haben
wir miro den meisten leuten wird das sicherlich schon ein begriff sein nee aber wenn ich
blöd vorkomme habe ich ja nie gehört den leuten die schon professionelle erfahrung
im bereich der softwareentwicklung haben ich benutze mir regel nur konfront ich habe keine
ahnung was mir davon erzählt habe dass miro ein sponsoring mit mir machen wird war sie
super begeistert denn sie arbeitet im marketing bereich arbeitet aber selbst auch täglich
mit miro miro ist ein virtuelles whiteboard mit dem man gemeinsam mit anderen personen
gleichzeitig ideen ausarbeiten kann es würde gar keinen sinn ergeben alle funktionen zu
zeigen denn dafür bräuchte man wahrscheinlich zehn wie aber wenn das ist eine werbung jetzt
verstehe ich das whiteboard zu machen mein das ist das ist sehr laut jetzt verstehe
ich ganz ehrlich ich habe ich habe von dem tool noch nix gehört keine ahnung mag ja
wirklich richtig poc sein ich habe keine ahnung co-pilot ja über den github alltag
in co-pilot kostet mittlerweile leider was und wenn du jetzt denkst verdammt was redet
der was ist überhaupt der github co-pilot stell es dir mal vor aber co-pilot ist wirklich
nice code autofahr vollständigung auf steroide denn die künstliche intelligenz und da steckt
wirklich künstliche intelligenz drin also das problem löst wird nur co-pilot ist wirklich
nice also ganz ehrlich da mache ich meistens irgendwelche focus work youtube playlists
oder sowas an und gut ist so fallsystem das internet versus das jugendwort des jahres
so viel verdient eine zugbegleiterin wahrscheinlich viel zu wenig für den scheiß den die sich
den ganzen tag anhören muss
day in the life of a software engineer linkedin was haltet ihr davon chat meint ihr die arbeiten
diesmal was oder die sind wieder nur am rumlaufen und und smoothies machen temple os in 100
sekunden müssen wir uns auch noch angucken
ich sag's euch aber reißt euch zusammen ok auf geht's 8 uhr wake up
ok erstmal gesicht eingreben alles klar ist wichtige sache ok acht uhr auf geht's
ich bin schon mal begeistert die steht zu sagen wir noch halbwegs normalen zeiten auf
ich meine mir persönlich wenn ich auf die arbeit fahren muss ist acht uhr fast entticken
zu spät also ich bin früher immer 5 45 aufgestanden auf aufgestanden das mache ich mittlerweile
auch nicht mehr das war mir tatsächlich chat ich habe gesagt reißt euch zusammen es geht
schon los ich wusste ich wusste sobald ich gesehen habe das ist eine programmierung was
mir klar dass der chat sich an manchen stellen wieder nicht zusammen reißen kann früher
bin ich 5 45 aufgestanden das ist mir eindeutig zu früh da bin ich nicht mehr in der lage
zu denken normal dabei aber acht uhr ist mir insofern auch ein bisschen zu spät weil
wenn du dann acht stunden arbeiten musst und erst um acht uhr aufstehst dann bist du
um neun oder zehn erst auf der arbeit und du musst achten uhr kannst du dann erst raus
ist halt auch müll
so das video ist zu einem viertel vorbei und wir haben jetzt erst 20 minuten des tages
aber aber ist das schon arbeitszeit eher nicht oder weiß nicht wie wie moderne bei
linkedin sind
ok ein finde ich ja schon mal realistisch die steht auf ist was fährt zur arbeit setzt
sich dann an ihren platz ohne sie zu aus als würde sie jetzt arbeiten ich bin übrigens
immer noch es ist mir immer noch ein absolutes rätsel wie es viele leute die bei den ganzen
reifert companies arbeiten wie die das immer schaffen ohne maus und tastatur zu arbeiten
ok 9 uhr anfangen zu arbeiten ok ist normal würde ich jetzt mal sagen
ja das mache ich morgens auch als erstes ich gucke ich gucke immer teams und gucke
immer mails und mal ob irgendwo was irgendwelche tickets einer was rein gepostet hat stonks
werden gecheckt beste big stonks
es ist neun uhr der day ist aber
park höhenverstellbarer schreibtisch moment chat chat sehe ich das richtig die arbeitet
den größten teil des tages was was ist denn was ist denn da los ich dachte die warum spielt
die kein billiard oder so oder kein tisch kicker oder kein pong oder keine wie oder
oder warum ist sie nicht in der kantine oder warum schild die nicht auf der terrasse oder
warum was ist denn da los warum arbeitet die dann
eckermodus aktiviert
das ist ja mal wirklich ein realistisches video die hat morgens angefangen ist auf
die morgens aufgescheint auf die arbeit gefahren und hat dann gearbeitet bis zum mittagessen
ja warte minute das ist wie jetzt die wollen wirklich sagen die arbeitet da ganz normal
poggers burger pock pock tasty
das sieht äußerst gesund aus
ich weiß ich bin wahrscheinlich nicht normal aber ich weiß nicht ich kann so nicht arbeiten
ich muss am schreibtisch sitzen und brauche meine ruhe ich brauche eine tastatur und eine
maus
und den tag fünf man den schreibtisch wechselt auch keinen bock drauf
so und jetzt ist gleich 18 uhr oder so weil das video ist gleich vorbei habt ihr fest
schreibt ihr ja naja ja und nein wir haben wir haben zwar theoretisch feste plätze also
sprich wenn du im teams nachguckst wo jemand sitzt dann dann sieht man das aber wir haben
auch arbeitsplätze wo man sich einfach so hinsetzen kann und auch so kleine schalltisch
büros wo man wenn man wenn dann alles abfuckt wo man reingehen kann moment ok das video
ist ja tatsächlich wirklich realistisch die so macht du aufgestanden um 9 Uhr angefangen
zu arbeiten um 1730 geht zu heim also sprich die hat einfach jetzt auf der arbeit gearbeitet
und geht dann heim und und macht nicht erst noch karaoke mit den buddies von der arbeit
oder sowas das ist ja tatsächlich mal ganz normaler realistischer arbeitstag ja das
ist ja mal einfach ganz normaler arbeitstag wie jetzt das deckt sich überhaupt überhaupt
nicht mit den anderen videos ja na voll langweilig die machen keine smoothies die spielen keinen
pong und sonst was den ganzen tag linkedin ist nicht agil anscheinend sind die aber agil
genug dass keine maxing verwenden will da wirklich viel mitbekommen hast du nicht aber
immerhin auch deutlich realistischer als das was wir in anderen videos bisher gesehen haben
zum größten teil zumindest so wir gucken uns jetzt an templo s in 100 sekunden auf
gehts in open source 64 bit operating system designed to be the third temple brage leute
bitte einmal in chat einmal in chat es passt es hat noch nie so gut gepasst wie jetzt präge
einmal präge dann mache ich das video auch weiter ok gut gut
it was created in 2005 by terry davis an exceptionally talented programmer der typ
hatte ziemlich in dachschaden diagnosed with schizophrenia he wrote the entire operating
system himself at his parents house in las vegas which included a bootloader kernel window
manager 3d graphics library and multiple games all powered by his own compiler and custom
programming language called holy see amazing i dachte als ich das das erste mal gesehen
habe das war irgendeine verarschung oder so aber nein es ist das ernst ich weiß dass
der typ in dachschaden haben muss siehst du schon bei solchen aussagen oder i am god's
josen josen programmer da weißt du schon der kell kann immer ganz dicht sein described
as a modern day way of speaking in tongues it renders graphics at 640 by 480 resolution
limited to only 16 colors the underlying language holy see resembles c or c++ but has functions
that can be invoked without parentheses or arguments and uses just in time compilation
which means it doubles as a shell language that can be executed directly from the terminal
unlike other operating systems like linux or windows it's ring zero only which means
everything happens directly in the kernel including user programs you have complete
control over the operating system source code and hardware that may not seem very safe but
it's the way it is because it's fun to get started you'll first want to download the
iso file from the temple os website from there use a tool like virtual box configured for
a 64-bit operating system that boots this file on startup it creates a single immortal
task named adam it's the father of every other task just like in normalerweise wird
es halt sagen dass es muss satire sein aber nein ist es nicht der meister ist wirklich
ernst the book of genesis it can also take advantage of multiple cpu cores where each
core gets its own immortal seth task once inside you can take the tour or immediately start
speaking in tongues by hitting f7 which generates a pseudo random word from god you can also
have god draw you a picture with shift f6 kannst du mit gott sprechen über die shell nicht schlecht
perform a god doodle that was fun but now use control m to open up the personal menu from here
you'll find a huge variety of games like 3d first-person shooters 2d strategy games and
simulations like after egypt where you play the role of moses and also has utilities to manage
your finances and make music where der kelp muss und also siehst du mal was so ein dachschaden
alles bewirken kann ja berth this is all made possible by a custom graphics library if you're not
happy with the way it works simply open up the source code make some modifications and holy see
reboot and enjoy every line of code is right at your fingertips thanks to the red sea file system
the end result is one of the most complex pieces of software ever written by a solo developer but
there's a lot more to this story and sadly terry davis passed away in 2018 at the age of 48 he
was both a highly controversial internet personality and genius programmer this has been temple os in
100 seconds hit the like button if you want to see more weird videos like this thanks for watching
and i will see you in the next one
der typ hatte wirklich also das kann man nicht anders sagen da hatte wirklich eine ernsthafte
psychische bestörung ja also der hatte wirklich nicht mehr alle tassen im schrank aber sieht man
mal was das bewirken kann das heißt ja nicht automatisch dass die leute blöd sind der ist
richtig big brain gewesen der kerl er hat sich halt sachen eingebildet die es nicht gibt aber ok
machen viele subscriber auf twitch auch
oder generell viele leute bilden sich sachen ein dies gar nicht gibt so
was ist das jetzt eine copypasta oder was was man hier lesen und hören muss ist ja hart grenzwertig
was man hier lösen und hören muss ist ok na dann wie kann ich meine firma überzeugen temple
es in production einzusetzen erst mal docker container draus bauen
nee der kerl der war wirklich gestört man weiß man weiß glaube ich gar nicht ob es selbstmord
war also man weiß gar nicht ob der sich umgebracht hat er wurde glaube ich von einem
zug überfahren und man weiß bis heute nicht ob das ob er sich quasi umgebracht hat oder
ob der einfach nur blöd von zug gelaufen ist also der war wirklich durch hast du schon ein
bisschen mit image generation ki rumgespielt nein war das der der erzählen dass er von der
cia verfolgt wird nach keine ahnung der hatte halt doch echt einen ziemlich harten dachschaden
ich habe ich noch nicht aber ich habe mir heute morgen in blog eintracht über open ai durchgelesen
und ich bin aber überlegen das mal auszuprobieren ein paar credits credits aufladen und los geht's
dann generiere ich einfach meine youtube thumbnails in zukunft nur noch per ai und dann ai stonks
jetzt schaue ich mir hier bestimmt nicht an da bin ich noch gar nicht gekommen mehr ja
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich wollte ursprünglich freebsd verwenden an den teufel gesehen als
maskottchen da ging das nicht da muss da muss templo es her so also kann man so irgendwas
angucken mein hals ist echt immer noch ziemlich pence champ das internet versus das jugendwort
des jahres ok was ist denn das jugendwort des jahres 2022 sus ne ne jugendwort ist das
sind die top 10 ok zeig mal her gomma mode das hat bestimmt nichts mit gomma dem minecraft
server zu tun oder das spricht man doch bestimmt anders aus leute wie spricht man das aus das
müsst ihr den boomer in mir mal erklären wie sagt man es sie sie oder muss man das
lang ziehen oder wie spricht man das aus ok was nee nicht wirklich oder
ich muss mich in doch anscheinend anscheinend spricht man das so aus alles klar ok das wild
ok das kenne ich das kenne ich das ist aber doch auch nichts digga alter wie lange ist
dieses wort schon angesagt drei vier jahre digga warum ist das jetzt erst warum ist das
ja jetzt erst dritte mache bodenlos slay sus bro aha gibt es da nicht bessere wörter für
die liste ist bodenlos ok also das internet versus das jugendwort des jahres
2014 mit dem bild von einem jungen erik kartmann im hitler kostüm irgendwo in den weiten eines
autistischen internet forums deutschland braucht eure hilfe es gibt ein wortum für das jugendwort
des jahres 2014 momentan führt ein türkisches wort und wir wollen es vernichten und ersetzen
mit dem wort farbieren was so viel da kann ich mich auch dran erinnern es wäre eine große
ehre für uns und so stürzten sich ein haufen mutige helden auf die seite und stimmten für
selbstbefriedigung bei jungs ab doch sie erreichten ihre geballten kraft gerade mal zwölf prozent
deswegen läuft bei dir und der durch ks rebel entstandene hype um das wort hi waren war zu
mächtige definitiv ok das kenne ich nicht geht auf diese seite da oben und wurde dafür ab der
ansturm an hi waren wurden in 14 jährigen war so enorm dass ein neuer plan her musste und so
kreierten die freiheitskämpfe eine exakt gleichaussehende jugendwort des jahres facebook
seite leiten diese hoch und machten dort indirekt werbung für das wort die intelligentesten köpfe
programmierten derweil einen bot der in regelmäßigen abständen mit unterschiedlichen
ips für farbieren abschneiden parallel wurde versucht sich zu bewerben um farbieren von
innen heraus an die spitze zu bringen der plan war genial doch bald zeigte sich schon der nächste
gegner ungespielt macht es sich über den momentan platz eins farbieren auf twitter lustig er möchte
es nicht zulassen dass dieses dumme wort gewinnt und forderte somit die leute auf für läuft bei
dir zu wohnen und somit war der jugendwort krieg eröffnet durch die massa teilnehmende leuten
fing außerdem das erste läuft bei dir ist doch schon total das ist ja schon fast boomer sprache
mittlerweile an personen zu nitschen es wurde zwar versucht jegliche personen zu identifizieren
und auszulöschen aber es war bereits zu spät der plan war aufgeflogen und ab dem zeitpunkt bekam
unsere helden das erste mal die verdiente mediale aufmerksamkeit mit einer internetumfrage sucht
wörterbuchverlag langenscheid das beliebteste jugendwort des jahres der begriff der momentan
klarer spitzenreiter ist ist auch der bizarste das kunstwort soll selbstbefriedigung bei
jungs bedeuten nun alle hoffnungen verloren waren dass wir hier tatsächlich von der jury
akzeptiert wird gab es nur noch ein ziel das wort hayvan mit den denurin zu reißen der plan
die erlaubten hayvan seinen stark muslimischen kreisen ein synonym für homosexuelle was somit
schwulenfeindlich macht und deswegen als jugendwort nicht angenommen werden darf und so schrieben die
verpieren kundesseure mehrere leserbriefe an zeitungen und fluteten ganz twitter mit dem
hashtag queers gegen hayvan und auf der fake face oh gott die leute haben probleme mann
rucksalte wurden derweil aufklärende post zu erstellen florian erklärt machen warum das wort hayvan diskriminierend ist und disqualifiziert werden muss
das ziel unseres projekts ist es voneinander zu lernen jegliche leute stimmten über die kommenden
wochen weiter ab und schicken ihre wörter ein als die ergebnisse feststanden war man empört
verpieren ist nicht auf der eins geblieben nein verpieren ist nicht mal mehr in den top fünf aufzufinden
denn die jury hat sich dazu entschieden das wort einfach zu verbannen weil angeblich nur
internetrolle dafür gestimmt haben eins schlag ins gesicht und die redewendung läuft bei dir war
auch noch der sieg die schlacht war verloren doch der krieg noch lange nicht im jahr darauf wurde
das jugendwort des jahres es momi eine mischung aus smart das hat doch nie jemand verwendet dieses
wort oder und somit und hier stürzen sich auch das erste mal neugierige facebook mitte auf das
smartphone phänomenen und erschufen somit ihre ersten mienversuche kindheit ohne handy ich war
dabei kopf hoch smartphone ist heilbar man sollte das überall hinstellen die jugend heutzutage so
traurig wie die kids heute spielen oh mein god das ist ziemlich tiefgründig handy böse handy macht
frau tote oh mein gott das buch macht ich regenbogen aliens kommen aber alle sind am handy der böse
wifi wird alle fressen das fand ich tatsächlich ganz lustig das ist so lustig ha ha ich muss
sagen den heilfisch fand ich wirklich nicht schlecht das eigentliche jugendwort des jahres
2015 sollte alpha kevin werden was ich erinnere mich dunkel dran da war was ja und schon teils
in grund und boden grosset wurden dies wurde dann aber wegen kevin feindliche diskriminierung
abgeschafft 2016 entschied sich die jury dann für fleißen und 2017 wurde es der ausdruck
die bims doch welche überaus witzige personen war das war das denn ich gerade sie kunde das
wurde dies wurde dann aber wegen kevin feindliche diskriminierung abgeschafft 2016 entschied sich
die jury dann für fleißen und 2017 wurde was macht er eigentlich schon ewig nichts gehört
doch welche überaus witzige personen kamen eigentlich auf die bims und von sprache im
jahr 2015 erklärte eine person namens willi nachdenklich er sei der erfinder dieser sprache
dieser führte auch eine facebook seite auf der er sehr lustige bilder teilte als dieser
dann stück für stück ist doch tatsächlich nicht schlecht also als dieser dann stück
für stück in medienberichten auftauchte entschied er sich nicht nur dazu super witzige
artikel zu verkaufen sondern auch live aufzutreten und aus seinem buch eins gutes buch von humor
her vorzulesen die luftfeuchtigkeit in wohnungen von alte leute ist generell viel höher da die
viel genüge dünsten und sonst auch viel mit kochenden wasser machen doch als twitter natürlich
wieder twitter merkte wie viel geld willi damit machte gegen sie dieser humorlosen sprache auf
die spur der eigentliche erfinder ist nämlich der bau im self ist der beste moment wie hieß er
und so entstand der hashtag kein applaus für willi in dem man versuchte willi zu boykottieren
und später als der schittstorm langsam abflachte versuchte dann eine werbung in der tour die
fogensprache patentieren zu lassen um sich rechte an super witzigen merch artikeln zu
sichern natürlich erfolglos und ganze fünf jahre später sind auch die ersten alten menschen
auf facebook auf die sprache aufmerksam geworden 2018 hat sich daneben bruder muss los und lauch
das wort ehrenmann durchgesetzt und damit waren die leute eigentlich relativ zufrieden 2019
fiel die wahl aus angeblich weil der verlag gewechselt wurde und sie schlichtweg keine
zeit hatten ein einziges eingabefeld zu organisieren jedoch gibt es das gerücht dass russen die seite
gehackt haben weil das wort routinieren was so viel heißt wie das kann auch nicht wirklich
und so stand die wahl für 2020 vor der tür und es gab keine jury soll ab nun selbst entscheiden
und so sollte das erste mal in der geschichte vom jungen wort des jahres ein wort gewählt werden
was allen gefällt ein wort was universal einsetzbar ist für wirklich alle leute es
war gut und so wirklich alle leute wollten dass es gut und gut denn wörter wie das kann
die doch das kann ja nicht wirklich in den jungen wort auf dem so einen schönen köfte
schweißen was so no front marschala konnten alle nichts ausrichten gegen die alles überschattende
macht von und natürlich programmiert jemand wieder ein wort der regelmäßig für das wort
so unabstimmte mensch das kam jetzt unerwartet doch langzeit fand das gar nicht gut und so
entschieden sie sich dazu das erste mal in zwölf jahren ein richtiges statement zu bringen es
kursiert das gerücht dass das wort das jugend wort 2020 werden soll doch langenscheid prüft
alle wörter zuvor auf diskriminierung und beleidigungen und entfernt diese entsprechend
demnach wird nicht in den top 10 erscheinen das beleidigt doch jetzt kein konkret oder
ich meine das ist halt das ist halt eine universell einsetzbare beleidigung es geht
dagegen kein jetzt irgendwie speziell widerlage für jeden redditor und turent und doch wenn
langenscheid jedes mal mit in die wahl angreift weil ihnen die wörter nicht gefallen dann
schauen wir doch mal welche wörter langenscheid selber in zwölf jahren jugend wort des seires
in die engere auswahl brachte mercules mischung aus angela merkel und hercules selphie zeit tot
durch ein selfen textmarker augen das bezahl alles kein menschen verwendet stark betonte
augenbrauen kokta im zeit die männer untereinander was koktaim koktaim koktaim koktaim koktaim
sorry sorry raumschiff eine bezeichnung für super oder toll hallo du bist echt raumschiff
senfautomat anderes wort für besserwisser eigentlich sollte man marihuana ja merkel ein
anderes wort für nicht zu tun laser noch ein wort für super oder toll hallo du bist echt
laser tmi hose hose bei der mehr zu sehen ist als am liebsten y o l b e kurzform von
you only live bis eltern spricht haus bambus ein anderes wort für cool sein luten wort für
einkaufen gehen dap oh mein gott nicht der dap nein nicht der dap nicht der dap nicht
und hier liegt doch das problem all diese nominierten wörter werden nicht von einer einzigen
jugendlichen gesprochen doch mit der veränderten wahl 2021 sollte noch mal alles anders werden
nominiert für das jugendwort 2021 waren es ist montag mittwoch mittwoch mittwoch mittwoch
mittwoch Luxus gering verdient Disney so genug schabannt schabern
jagt
w cache
Und so zogen alle Armeen in den Krieg und stimmten für ihr perfektes Jugendwort des
Jahres und die Schlacht war eröffnet.
Was bin ich, was bin ich sehend?
Na ja, so ähnlich sah das dann aus.
Eigentlich wurden nur lustige Memes gepostet und die Wörter, die sich dann am meisten
durchsetzen konnten, für die wurde dann auch gevotet.
Und dann war es sobald die Top 10 stand fest und das erste Mal in der Geschichte der Tagesschau
öffentlich...
Ja, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob da mal einer im Team bei der Tagesschau mal wirklich ein
bisschen Weitsicht hatte, diesen Clip raus zu bringen, wo die das vorliest.
Das Feedback war gemixt, neben gefühlt 1 Milliarden unangenehmer TikTok Videos waren die Leute
erstaunt darüber, wie Susanne die Wörter wie Lottozahlen runterliest.
Und zwei Monate später war die Abstimmung zu Ende und die Tagesschau war diesmal vorbereitet
wie noch nie.
1000 IQ Move, den ihr auftretenden Shitstorm kontern, in dem man selber bereits vorwegnimmt,
dass man cringe ist.
Cringe konternd mit cringe.
Das Wort kam zwar wie gewohnt mal wieder zwei Jahre zu spät, jedoch waren diesmal alle
zufrieden, denn das erste Mal beschreibt das Jugendwort des Jahres das Jugendwort des
Jahres.
Und für 2022 gibt es schon ein paar Vorschläge, wie zum Beispiel Anthrozopoulos, welcher einfach
nur der Name von dem Autor ist, der über den Mitwossforsch geschrieben hat.
Ich persönlich habe auf meinem Twitter für Bosscock geworben und falls ihr euch...
Was?
...den Bosscock ist eine Bewegung, außerdem kann man Bosscock in jedes andere Wort füllen,
zum Beispiel, ich hab heute wieder mal geBosscocked oder ich möchte mit vielen Leuten Bosscocken.
Außerdem stört der Bosscock das Gemeinschaftsgefühl untereinander, sobald man mehrere Leute findet,
welche auch viele von dem Bosscock halten.
Das war Bushidoos am Blick, als er den Bosscock gesehen hat, das muss ja was heißen, oder?
Danke, das sind noch die Krieger des Bosscocks und nun ja, wart ihr schon mal auf einer Bosscock
Party?
Da kommen Leute mit dem Bosscock an und es gibt richtig wilde Züge, da gibt es noch Bosscock
Merch und das ist echt unfassbar, ich lege meine Hand dafür ins Feuer, dass Bosscock
das Jugendwort des Jahres...
Da wäre ich auch dafür, was haben wir?
Was gibt es denn zu aus, weil also von Bosscock bin ich auch...
Ist da Bosscock dabei?
Nee...
Ab-Stimmung...
Wo kann man abstimmen?
Wo ist das Ballangenschein, ist das doch immer, oder?
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wo ich bin, ich bin jetzt zu dumm, das Wort zu finden, wo man
da abstimmen kann.
Scheine ich schon durch, aber Bosscock, also da könne ich mich tatsächlich mit anfreunden,
also von den Sachen, die es hier zur Auswahl gibt, also ganz im Ernst, was fand ich Bosscock
eigentlich am besten, ja?
Ich mein, S.U.S. ist eigentlich ja schon wieder out, mein Digger ist daueraktuell, wild irgendwo
auch, was Gommemode sagt, ich hab keine Ahnung, das wird wahrscheinlich nichts mit Minecraft
zu tun haben.
Was, das hat was mit Minecraft zu tun, das ist doch seit, keine Ahnung, acht Jahren,
aber Bosscock hätte ich nicht schlecht gefunden, ruhig sagen, also hätten wir mal kein Corona
gehabt und hätten das etwas früher rausbekommen, dann hätten wir ein Bosscock-Vote-Bot programmiert.
Insie-Modus, Insie-Modus wäre auch ein supergeiles Jugendwort geworden, Insie-Modus, also Insie-Modus
wird mir fast noch besser gefallen als Bosscock, oh Mann, ok, jetzt sind wir wieder voll auf
aktuellen Stand, was die Zoomersprache angeht, jetzt weiß ich Bescheid.
Ah, kurz was trinken, Leute, mein Hals tut weh, glaub ich war jetzt aufzustremen, aber
wirklich lustig, also Bosscock, das muss ich mir merken, das muss ich in meinem Sprachgebrauch
aufnehmen.
Massive drei Milliarden Bits, welche Plane ist das, das ist, Moment, Top 50 Mario Songs
of All Time, die Bosscock-Playlist, also wenn nächstes Jahr programmieren wir einen Bot,
der abstimmt, ja, ging ja gar nicht so sehr darum, ging eher um den Umstieg von Windows
auf Linux, warum das für viele Leute nix ist, Leute, ich müsste eigentlich ein neues
Video machen, fällt mir auf, jetzt wo Corona rum ist, ich hab hier schon 25 Tage kein Video
hochgeladen, mir fällt aber gerade so spontan kein Thema ein, ich hab mir in den letzten
Tagen auch keine Gedanken drüber gemacht, ich mein, ich könnte ein Video, so ein Low
Effort Video machen, ich hab Corona überlebt oder so, aber pff, wen juckt's, interessiert
doch keinem mehr, Stellanzeigen Video ist zu aufwendig, das krieg ich nicht an einem
Tag aus dem Ärmel geschüttelt, also falls jemand, falls jemand eine gute Idee hat, ja,
ja, dankeschön, ich bin jetzt 38 Leute übrigens, ich hab's geschafft, Reaction Content, nee,
das kann ich nicht auf YouTube machen, es gibt, eigentlich brauchen wir dazu gar nix
machen, Cooper, nee, das ist für das, was gewonnen hat, Stellanzeigen Video geht nicht,
das krieg ich nicht, da muss ich mir ein bisschen Gedanken zu machen und vor allem
ein paar raussuchen, das Video von ehemals Reaction und nee, Pog, sowas wär ja mal gar
nix für mich, da hat man mit Leuten zu tun oder auch noch mit gestörten Leuten, wobei
passt da eigentlich gut, nee, naja, das wird vielleicht, das ist ein guter Titel für
einen Stream, ich weiß nicht, aber nicht für ein YouTube Video, ja, Leute, zumindest, ich
bin froh, ich hab's zweieinhalb Stunden durchgehalten, gut, der Hals zwar weh ein bisschen, aber
ich muss mal, ich muss mal wieder online kommen, ich hab, ich hab Geruchsverlust, kein Geschmacksverlust,
aber ja, das könnte auch dazu führen, dass man C++ mag, Tierlisten, naja, was soll ich
Tierlisten, okay Leute, also, wir sehen uns, die Tage, es wird wahrscheinlich nicht bis
Sonntag dauern, denke ich, bis denn, macht's gut, see you.